[Musique]
Kemyba. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
YouTube qui s'appelle Syerview. On vous
reçoit dans le cadre de vos activités
panafricaines et votre dernier bouquin
l'Afrique ou la mort.
L'Afrique libre ou la mort.
L'Afrique libre ou la mort. Merci.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ? Seba, président de l'ONG
Urgence panafricaniste, chroniqueur
géopolitique pour diverses grosses
chaînes en Afrique francophone et
écrivain auteur de quatre ouvrage sur le
panafricanisme et la conscience noire en
général.
Euh c'est des des gens de notre
communauté qui nous ont demandé de de
vous interviewer euh pour parler du
France CFA parce qu'en ce moment on
s'intéresse au France CFA et on cherche
des des gens autour de ça et on nous a
dit que vous étiez très présents en
Afrique, que vous aviez un gros public,
on vous connaissait pas trop et puis on
a lu votre fiche Wikipédia et là on a
commencé à prendre peur. Bien sûr que si
vous lisez laaffiche Wikipédia écrit par
des gens qui s'arrogent le droit de
donner leur vision erronée sur des
personnes qui ne connaissent pas, c'est
sûr que vous aurez une vision erronée de
mon combat.
Donc on va commencer par la fiche
Wikipédia. On va essayer de de
commencer. Donc Kemy Sebban et Stelio
Gill Robert Capoishi. Ouais, Stelio
c'est le prénom que mes parents m'ont
donné qui est la traduction de Sebba
d'ailleurs. Sauf que Stelio c'est en
italien et comme vous le voyez à ma
tête, je ne suis pas italien donc j'ai
pris un nom africain.
Donc c'est bientôt votre anniversaire.
Le 9 décembre 80 à Strasbourg est un
activiste politique et séiste
franco-béninois figure radicale noire
euh figure du radicalisme noir et du
panafricanisme contemporain. Il officie
par ailleurs en tant que chroniqueur
télévision en Afrique. Initialement
brambre francophone de Nation of
l'Islam. Kimi seba ne fait se fait
d'abord connaître en France en tant que
fondateur et porte-parole de plusieurs
organisations notamment Tribua
Génération Kimba toutes deux dissoutes
par décret pour incitation à la reine
haine raciale. Pourquoi ça ? Quand on
veut tuer son chien, on accuse d'avoir
la rage ou d'avoir la haine. Sauf que je
ne suis pas un chien. Et à partir du
moment où en France, quelle que soit
votre couleur de peau, que vous soyez
noir, blanc, arabe, juif ou autres, dès
que vous dites des choses qui sortent un
peu des sentiers battus, et bien on vous
accuse d'être un quelqu'un qui appelle à
la haine. Ça évite de répondre au débats
de fond, aux questions de fond et de
permettre aux gens de dialoguer entre
eux. Voilà. Donc on m'appelle en France
le NE et paradoxalement
en Afrique, je suis plus que jamais
plébiscité par mon combat pour mon
combat politique. Donc je termine juste
les Celines Car se présentant comme
anti-impérialiste et antisioniste, il
est considéré par de nombreux
journalistes et politologues français et
étrangers comme un militant raciste,
antiblanc, racialiste et antisémite,
ainsi qu'adepte de l'action violente
dans les années 2000. Il est également
considéré comme un suprémiste noir.
C'est intéressant ça. C'est les comptes
de Walt Disney et adapté à la France.
C'est des sketchs sur lesquels je ne me
prononce que très peu parce que je
trouve que c'est tout simplement inepte
et stupide que dès que quelqu'un a un
discours qui sort de sentier battu en
France, on aime le noir quand il fait du
basket ou quand il s'appelle Kyan Mbappé
quand il fait du football ou quand il
fait du rap. s'il fait le Chevara dans
ses clips de rap mais qui se soumet en
dehors de ça, ça ne pose pas de
problème. Mais dès qu'on pose juste pour
terminer, excusez-moi, des questions de
fond et qu'on parle sur le fond des
sujets en tant que tel, qu'on parle de
l'élite de l'oligarchie occidentale et
de son élite coopt africaine qui est une
élite tout aussi corrompue.
On va y venir, vous en parlez beaucoup
dans votre bouquin sûr et ben on arrive
à une situation où on devient quelqu'un
qui appelle à la haine. C'est marrant
quand quand on a regardé des vidéos des
même des des anciennes vidéos, vous avez
encore des cheveux.
Ouais.
Beaucoup. C'est ça.
Je suis devenu saan depuis
là. Ouais, ça manque un peu de jaune sur
la tard.
Ouais, mais pource que je suis noir et
fier de l'
le pourquoi faire une descente dans la
rue des rosiers ?
Parce que le bétard, la ligue de défense
juif qui sont des organisations
interdites aux États-Unis terrifié les
gars là-bas.
Juste si vous voulez que j'explique,
j'explique. J'explique. OK. Donc il y
avait une organisation qui existe, je
suppose toujours, je les suis pas, je
sais même pas ce qu'ils font
aujourd'hui, qui s'appelle la Ligue des
défens juifs et Bétard qui avait tabassé
des noirs lors de la manifestation
commémoration de la mort d'Ilimi.
Et certains de ces noirs là, notamment
un papa ébouur de 50 ans à l'époque qui
avait pris des coups gratuitement parce
qu'il avait la malchance d'être noir
durant cette manifestation était venu
nous voir lors de l'une de nos
assemblées, l'une de nos réunions, l'un
de nos meetings que l'on tenait tous les
dimanches à Belleville en disant queil
ne comprenait pas qu'il se soit fait
tabasser lors de cette manifestation et
il voyait que ces gens-là se
revendiquaient du Bétard et de la Ligue
de défense juives. Ilan Alimi euh le il
s'est fait torturer, il fait
tout à fait. Est-ce que je peux
continuer l'histoire comme ça après on
revient sur Ilan, sur qui vous voulez ?
Et donc euh partant de ce principe- là,
nous on a pris contact avec euh donc
cette organisation disons pourquoi vous
agressez des noirs ? Si vous avez un
problème avec Youssoufana, vous vous
adressez à Youssoufana, ça nous pose
aucun problème. Mais quand vous
commencez à dire Youssoufana, salle
noire, les juifs auront ta peau et que
vous voyez des noirs, vous tabassez des
noirs, ça me pose problème. Là, on
rentre dans la reine. Si un criminel
noir se fait juger en tant que criminel,
ça ne me pose pas de problème. Les noirs
n'ont pas plus de droits ni moins de
droits que les autres. Mais si un blanc
tue quelqu'un, on ne du pas Jean Dupont
sale blanc, les noirs auront ta peau.
C'est ridicule. On j on juge le blanc
pour ce qu'il a fait. Quand euh Marque
du trou viole viole des enfants, on dit
pas sale blanc, les noirs auront ta
peau. C'est stupide. On s'attaque à euh
monsieur le violeur quel qu'il soit ou
le criminel. Donc on a pris contact avec
la ligue des fonds juif et le Bétard qui
paraît-il terroriser
les gens. J'avais appris ça. Moi j'ai
généralement je ne suis terrorisé par
personne et c'est une constante dans mon
combat politique depuis très longtemps
et ça ne changera pas. Et donc ils nous
ont dit bande de grande gueule en gros
ça vous pose quoi comme problème qu'on
est à bassé des noirs on fait ce qu'on
veut en France ce pays nous appartient
c'était leur langage. On a été mis sur
écoute donc les gens savent c'est pour
ça que j'ai été acquitté hein lors de
cette descente rue des Rogé. J'ai pas eu
de problème lors de cette occasion là à
cause de ça. Et ils nous ont donné
rendez-vous et le problème c'est que moi
quand on me donne rendez-vous je viens
toujours. Et donc je suis venu
accompagner des militants de notre
organisation à l'époque la tribuca.
Des fois un peu en retard
non ? Le l'heure de l'émission c'était
je crois 8h et je suis venu à 8h-10. Il
faut pas oublier qu'on est dans le
décalage horaire parce que je vis en
Afrique. Je suis juste venu pour vous et
pour mon stock de de livres et je repars
le lendemain dans de jours. Bref,
donc on s'est rendu on s'est rendu à
l'invitation. Quand on m'invite à un
anniversaire, je viens. Quand on
m'invite pour une rencontre, je viens.
Il se trouve que quand je suis venu, la
rue s'est écarté comme la mer rouge
devant Moïse. Ils sont tous rentrés dans
les restaurants Falafel. les mêmes qui
étaient des habitués pour tabasser
gratuitement aussi bien des juifs qui
s'opposent au colonialisme au
Moyen-Orient que des noirs, des Arabes
ou autres. Et ben quand ils nous ont vu,
ils ont laissé les gens sur le carreau
dans la rue, ils sont rentrés dans les
magasins, ils ont disparu. Il se trouve
qu'on avait pas d'armes, il y a pas eu
de coûp, il y a pas une seule violence
et c'est pour ça que je n'ai eu aucune,
je dis bien aucune condamnation
judiciaire pour cette descente qui
n'était en réalité qu'une rencontre.
simplement quand des noirs viennent de
manière disciplinée euh quels que soient
dans les endroits où ils se trouvent et
ben il se trouve que des gens qui
veulent instrumentaliser la situation
vont présenter ça d'une autre façon.
Donc parler de descente dans un quartier
juif c'était un beau titre pour les
médias. Je n'ai eu aucune condamnation.
La justice m'a entre guillemets,
j'allais dire blanchi, c'est le mauvais
terme, vous le voyez bien, mais m'a m'a
acquitté de toute charge lors de cette
descente en constatant qu'en effet, il y
avait pas eu de violence, il y avait
rien eu. Mais en effet, ça avait fait du
bruit. Sarkozi était en pleine campagne
présidentielle donc il s'est servi de
cette affaire pour dire des méchants
noirs, des nazis noirs.
On fait une descente dans quartier juif.
Moi, un juif n un juif qui n'a rien fait
ne me pose pas de problème. C'est un
frère en humanité comme un arabe, un
blanc, un noir ou autre. Par contre, il
y a des criminels dans toutes les
communautés et je il y a des gens qui
sont des oppresseurs dans toutes les
communautés et je ne vois pas pourquoi
j'aurais le droit de dénoncer tout ce
qui se passe dans toutes les
communautés, y compris dans la mienne,
mais que je n'aurais pas le droit de
pointer du doigt ce qui ne va pas chez
ces milices extrémistes. C'est ce que
j'ai fait. Elles ont bégayé ce jour-là
et euh parce qu'il savait très bien que
il n'avait pas les armes qu'il fallait
pour nous affronter, c'est rentrer dans
un débat politique et c'est par décision
politique qu'on a été interdite.
D'accord, en conseil des ministres.
C'est la première fois de l'histoire
qu'une organisation afroodescendante
était interdite sous la 5e République
soi-disant pour des propos d'incitation
laine raciale parce qu'on disait qu'on
allait s'occuper.
Oui. Mais bon, dès qu'on parle de
certaines choses, si je dis que Moïse ou
que je ne sais pas comment il s'appelle
aura un nom cassé, on va dire que je
suis antisémite. Il arrive un moment où
en France le débat il est il est
hystérisé. Euh on on a on n' pas le
droit en fait à cause peut-être d'un
sentiment de culpabilité de serp en
France ou pas, on n' pas le droit de
dire qu'il y a des choses qui peuvent ne
pas aller dans cette communauté. On a le
droit de dire tout chez tous les autres.
Je ne comprends pas pourquoi on a pas le
droit de dire ce qui ne va pas dans
cette communauté. Et moi j'ai un
problème. Je suis issu d'un peuple qui
est ostracisé, un peuple qui souffre le
martyre, je vis sur le continent depuis
maintenant 9 ans, d'accord ? qui vit
dans des conditions indécentes, y
compris en priorité à cause des
responsabilités de nos élites. Il faut
qu'on le dise aussi, nos élites
endogènes. On en reparlera tout à
l'heure. Et donc je suis très sensible
au de poids de mesure à l'injustice. Je
ne comprends pas que quand il y a des
propos inacceptables tenus chez des
blancs, chez des Arabes, chez des noirs,
il y a un consensus, tout le monde a le
droit de parler, mais une sorte
d'omerta. Comme si la population juive
serait une une population qui ne serait
pas en égalité avec les autres, comme si
on aurait pas le droit de dire qu'il y a
des choses qui ne vont pas chez les
autres. Vous êtes taxé direct
d'antisémite. Mais moi, j'ai un
problème, je m'en fous des étiquettes.
Voilà, je vais être très clair. Euh, je
ne veux pas être dans l'essentialisme.
Il y avait des périodes où je l'étais
peut-être de manière provocatrice parce
que j'ai bien compris dès lors que j'ai
senti qu'il y avait un tabou sur
certaines choses, moi je fonce. D'accord
? Donc je m'enfonce dans la chose.
Rentrer en Afrique m'a permis de d'avoir
beaucoup plus de distance critique sur
la question des confrontation entre
identité et de beaucoup plus analyser la
problématique des classes. Ce qui ne
veut pas dire que je suis non plus un
marxiste congénital en tant que tel.
Donc voilà un petit peu la situation. Et
est-ce que vous est-ce que vous leur
avez tendu la main depuis ? Est-ce que
vous avez essayé d'arranger les choses,
de vous comprendre, d'essayer j'ai pas
besoin de comprendre le béard les ligue
de défense juives. Ça m'intéresse pas de
les comprendre. Ils ont tabassé des
noirs. Fin de l'histoire. Le débat là,
on est en 2018, ça s'est passé en 2006.
Entre-temps, j'ai eu des enfants.
Entre-temps, j'ai connu un un accès au
mass médias en Afrique. Entre-temps,
notre combat a pris une ampleur sur le
continent africain. J'ai pas besoin de
parler de la Ligue de défendu et le
Bettard. Ils ne sont pas dans mon
agenda. Je ne sais même pas s'ils
existent encore au moment où je te
parle. Et je vais aller plus loin juste
pour terminer cette situation. Ça m'a
pas empêché durant toutes ces années de
rencontrer des juifs exceptionnels parce
qu'il y en a des
des noms.
Non, je veux pas te donner leur nom, ils
vont se faire tabasser par le B d'Égypte
peut-être, j'en sais rien. Mais plus
sérieusement, des citoyens lambda
normaux, d'accord, qui euh vivent euh
comme des êtres humains sur cette terre
et qui essayent de trouver le bonheur
comme des tas d'autres êtres humains sur
cette terre. Donc le problème, c'est pas
les juifs contre les noirs. Le problème,
c'est qu'il y a des voyoux dans toutes
les communautés. Et de la même façon que
quand il y a des choses qui vont pas
chez les nôtres, je suis le premier
moi-même à tout faire pour essayer de
faire avancer les choses dans la bonne
direction. Bah quand ça va pas chez
d'autres, je ne vois pas pourquoi on
devrait se mettre à Paradra sous
prétexte que c'est le peuple élu euh
entre guillemets. Sachant que sachant
que sachant que j'ai voté pour personne
à titre personnel. Le
le faire avec moins de violence
peut-être. Non.
Violence de quoi ? Il y a qu'en France
qu'on parle de violence. Faut qu'on se
rappelle des choses. En Afrique, j'ai
reçu je sais pas combien de prix. J'ai
reçu le prix MyPad que j'ai refusé, most
influential people of African Descent.
Vous voulez que j'aille à New York ?
J'ai refusé. J'ai reçu le prix Africa
News, prix de la personnalité politique
africaine de l'année. Africa News, c'est
la chaîne équivalente de Euronews en
Afrique. C'est la même filiale
d'ailleurs. Euh j'ai reçu le prix MGA
intellect. On me plébiscite pour mon
combat politique, pour l'influence que
j'ai sur la jeunesse africaine. Et de
l'autre côté en France, on me considère
comme un terroriste. Il y a un moment
peut-être il y a un problème, il y a une
double vision ou alors il y en a
peut-être qui aura besoin de lunettes.
Et dans la dans le même temps, on a Éric
Zemour qu'on laisse parler dans tous les
médias. Moi, je dirais le milliardième
de ce qu'il dit dans les médias. Je
serai déjà incarcéré. On m'a incarcéré
deux fois en France.
Alors, combien de fois vous avez fait de
la tôle et pourquoi ? Quelle combien de
temps ?
La première fois parce que soit-disant
les deux fois en France et une fois au
Sénégal. La première parce que j'étais
venu ouvrir une antenne dans mon
mouvement à Chartre et le préfet de la
région à Chartre avait
carrément sorti le plan Vigy Pirate en
disant que il fallait pas que je vienne,
que j'ouvre une antenne de quoi que ce
soit, que je suis quelqu'un de dangereux
pour l'ordre de public entre guillemets.
Et je avais dit vraiment vous j'ai dit
au policiers divisionnaires de l'époque
vous vous comportez comme un chien de
l'oligarchie sioniste en tant que tel.
Ça fait ça ça fait mal au cœur. Ça
faisait de la peine. Ils m'ont mis
outrage. Il m'a même dit violence alors
que je crois que je l'ai frôé. Enfin
bref. Et on m'a mis 2 mois en prison en
isolement. Et ceux qui ont fait de la
prison en isolement savent que c'est
comme si vous avez avaient fait beaucoup
plus longtemps en en partageant avec les
autres. C'était à Boisarci je crois. La
deuxième fois j'ai rencontré un proche
journaliste de Bernard Henry Lévi qui
avait fait un reportage diffamatoire sur
moi et moi je suis un homme de contact.
J'aime le peuple et j'aime l'humanité.
Et donc quand quelqu'un m sur moi, je
vais à sa rencontre et je lui demande
pourquoi tu racontes n'importe quoi sur
moi ? Il a eu la mauvaise attitude de me
de me souffler de la cigarette en plein
visage et me dire "J'ai pas envie de
parler avec toi alors que j'avais été
très courtois avec lui." Il m'a bousculé
alors que je n'avais rien fait. La
réponse n'appartient qu'à Dieu. Il se
trouve que j'ai eu un contrôle
judiciaire pour Busculade. On était
trois. Ils étaient deux, je crois. Il y
en a un qui a été innocenté ce qui l'a
pas donné de coup. En réalité, c'était
deux contre deux. Et euh
on m'a condamné à du churci. En réalité,
c'était un prétexte pour essayer de
m'immobiliser parce que ça faisait un
bout de temps que le procureur qui a eu
qui était en charge de l'affaire Non
mais j'y arrive. Si je donne mon
explication, tu comprendras peut-être un
peu mieux ou vous comprendrez peut-être
un peu mieux. Euh le procureur en
question qui s'appelait monsieur
Zukovic, ça faisait un an qu'il essayait
de me de me faire incarcérer dans tous
les procès que j'avais, ça ne marchait
pas. Et donc il s'est saisi de cette
occasion et malgré ça, il avait il avait
demandé un enferme. C'était délirant
pour quelques coups mais la juge a tenu
compte du fait que j'avais été bousculé
en premier et que je n'avais fait que
répliquer. Et donc elle m'a mis du
churci et euh j'étais semiassigné à
résidence. Je devais pointer réguliè une
fois par semaine ou deux fois par
semaine, je sais plus dans la ville où
j'étais. J'étais interdit de partir de
France et se trouve que moi je n'aime
pas trop qu'on me Donc ça c'est arrivé
en 2009. et je n'aime pas trop qu'on me
régule.
J'ai depuis tout petit, j'ai toujours
été quelqu'un un petit peu de qui était
borderline par rapport à la loi. Je
n'aime pas qu'on m'impose des choses.
J'aime la liberté. Et donc en 2011, j'ai
eu une offre pour être le porte-parole
d'une société qui prenait le retour des
afroodescendants sur le continent qui
créait des pépinières de renracinement
au Sénégal. Et donc, j'ai pas demandé
l'autorisation à la juge en disant
"Micheline, est-ce que je peux aller
au Sénégal ?" Je suis parti et euh ce
qui est intéressant juste pour terminer
dessus et après bon l'histoire du
Sénégal ceux qui doivent la connaître la
connaissent. Ça s'est très bien passé
jusqu'à il y a quelques temps et
paradoxalement je je faisais des
allers-retours réguliers entre l'Afrique
et la France parce que contrairement à
ce que mes adversaires politiques ont
dit, je suis pas parti d'Afrique de
France parce que j'avais des ennuis
juridiques. Sinon, je serais jamais
revenu. Je revenais régulièrement voir
la famille, voir les amis et cetera,
faire des meetings de temps en temps. On
me dérangeait pas parce que la les
dirigeants français s'étaient dit
peut-être que il est rentré en Afrique,
c'est bon, il va il va nous casser les
il va cesser de nous casser les pieds
avec son combat politique pour la
souveraineté des populations africaines.
Il est dans un truc qui a l'air beaucoup
plus de réenracinement culturel. Et en
fait quand j'ai commencé à travailler à
la télévision en 2013 et que l'audience
a explosé sur le continent africain,
c'est quoi explosé ? Bah écoute, c'est
que le rapport des africains à la
télévision est très différent des
Européens à la télévision qui eux les
occidentaux ont beaucoup plus accès
internet. En Afrique, le rapport à
internet n'est pas encore aussi
développé. Tout le monde n'a pas
internet au pays mais tout le monde a la
télévision. Et donc je passais dans les
émissions qui sont diffusées dans toute
l'Afrique de l'Ouest, une des émissions
phare qui s'appelait le grand
rendez-vous qui est l'équivalent un
petit peu de on n'est pas couché de
ruquier en moins stupide je pense et qui
est plus adapté aux réalités africaines
locales où on intervie des ministres des
artistes des personnalités du continent
africain et donc qui était je crois que
le grand rendez-vous a été l'une des
plus grosses a été nommé la meilleure
émission l'une des meilleures émissions
politiques d'Afrique de l'Ouest 2 ans de
suite ou 3 ans de suite et moi j'avais
le rôle de Zemour en en Moi
je vais pas rentrer dans trop de
détails.
Si si on a le temps.
Bon c'est pas en tout cas c'est pas
l'orientation politique de Zemour, c'est
sûr sur bon nombre de points. Mais donc
problème avec Zemour ?
Non je vais venir sur Zemour. J'ai pas
dit que j'ai un problème avec lui.
Simplement je trouve que il il a le
droit de dire des choses euh toujours
face à des personnes faibles. Face à
Absatoui. C'est très facile de de dire
ce qu'il a dit. Moi Zemour je le vois en
face et on discutera d'un certain nombre
de choses. J'ai pas de problème quand il
dit que quand tu es français tu veux
prendre un nom français. Il y a aucun
souci. Mais Zemour toujours jouer le
plus royaliste que le roi en en oubliant
que lui-même n'est pas français.
D'accord. C'est un juif
algérien à la base d'origine. Euh
on s'en fout qu'il soit juif.
Non mais c'est pas la question qu'il
soit juif. Il peut même être norvégien
si tu veux. Si ça te rend plus à l'aise,
ça te stresse moins. Je veux dire qu'il
est norvégien. S'il y a un norvégien
mais
donc j'y arrive j'y arrive. c'est que
quelqu'un qui vient qui vient d'arriver
ou qui est arrivé il y a pas si
longtemps, son père était dans un autre
pays et qui veut commencer à monter
d'autres communauté parce que ça arrange
ses intérêts en réalité, son logiciel
idéologique, ça me pose problème parce
que l'axe de d'Éric Zemour, c'est de
faire en sorte que les noirs et les
Arabes se fassent taper dessus ou se
tapent contre les blancs et que lui et
sa communauté soient du côté des blancs.
Ça devient en gros l'axe judéo-chrétien
contre l'axe [__] arabo musulman. Ben,
je trouve que c'est stupide et que c'est
ceux qui généralement sont des pièces
rapportées et qui jouent les rois plus
que la royauté elle-même finissent
toujours par être les dadons de la
farce. Et donc Eric Zemmor devrait être
très prudent dans la manière dont il
monte les uns contre les autres. Moi ça
ne me pose pas de problème qu'il disent
que il voudrait qu'Asatou s'appelle
Julie ou Séverine mais Zemour à mes yeux
n'est pas plus français qu'Apsatou.
C'est la seule chose que j'ai à dire. il
chantent les louanges de la France et ça
ça fait rêver euh des Français qui
malheureusement puisque dans leur
télévision il y a plus de Français qui
parlent et euh il y a très peu de gens
qui sont issus de la France entre
guillemets de souche qui parlent. Donc
quand il y en a un qui chante les
valeurs dites patriotique même s'il est
pas français, ils sont contents. Mais il
arrivera un moment où je pense que la
population française va se rendre compte
elle-même que le ZMour en question c'est
quelqu'un qui a un agent extérieur et
qui ne roule pas pour les intérêts de la
France. Je ferme ma parenthèse par
rapport à lui. Et donc quand j'ai fini
la télévision, quand je suis rentré à la
télévision parton et que euh l'audience
a commencé à augmenter, que j'ai
rencontré d'Armadinjad, que j'ai
rencontré des lieutenants d'Hugo Chavez
au Venezuela et cetera, que j'ai
commencé à voyager un peu partout, à
prendre un peu de tune de de l'Iran. Non
non, ça c'est ce que les abrutis disent.
Tu sais, je suis surveillé par les
services français depuis très longtemps
déjà.
Lesquel ? Lesquels ? Non, bon il y a les
services.
Bon, j'étais avait la section
antiterroriste du commandant Laorio en
à partir de 2008 jusqu'à 2012 où j'ai eu
en ce que j'appelle des interviews.
C'estàd que j'ai été convoqué parce que
surveillé en tant que tel. J'ai jamais
posé de bon mais pour eux visiblement
les propos qu'on donne ça pouvait poser
problème par rapport à certains
intérêts. Euh et à côté de ça, il y a
les services français extérieurs. Je
crois qu' avant on appelait ça des GSE.
Je pense plus qu'on appelle ça
maintenant. Et euh je suis suffisamment
surveillé pour te dire que si j'étais
financé par l'Iran, ça se saurait. Mais
moi, j'ai un défaut, c'est que dès qu'on
jette un anathème sur moi, ça ne me
dérange absolument pas d'être le diable
dans le regard de mes adversaires. Donc
je ne démands pas, mais j'ai jamais
touché 1 € de l'Iran. J'étais par contre
reçu par un Madinad à trois reprises, à
deux reprises, pardon. C'est quelqu'un
qui apprécie beaucoup mon travail. Si tu
veux une confidence, j'ai été reçu aussi
au Venezuela euh par celui qui est
maintenant euh l'ambassadeur du
Venezuela en Afrique de l'Ouest et dit
Rosé Corsga. D'accord. qui apprécie
beaucoup aussi mon travail. Euh, j'ai
été en Russie, d'accord, j'ai été reçu
par Alexandre Dougin, un des conseiller
des autorités russes qui apprécie
beaucoup.
Comment vous êtes rentré en relation
avec lui ?
On s'est rencontré.
J'ai pas besoin de te dire plus, on
s'est rencontré. La connexion s'est
faite par des personnes en qu'on a en
commun et qui apprécient beaucoup mon
travail. et euh toutes les personnes qui
en ont marre du de la globalisation, de
l'uniformisation du monde, qui en ont
marre qu'on veulent imposer un schéma
civilisationnel de société au reste du
monde, elles finissent toujours par se
retrouver. Et donc c'est pour ça me fait
rire l'histoire de l'anti blanc parce
que je pense qu'il y a pas plus blanc
que de ce côté-là du Caucase. Mais on
s'est rencontré, ça a été une très belle
rencontre intellectuelle et politique
philosophique aussi. Est-ce que vous
êtes pas la un peu la pièce rapportée né
à Strasbourg qui se prend un peu plus
roi que le roi et qui veut être roi
d'Afrique apprendre le panafricanisme,
je voulais être roi. Je vais te dire un
truc he il y a beaucoup d'élections et
de beaucoup de partis puissants qui
l'orignion sur mon audience en Afrique
parce que celui qui veut jouer plus roi
que le roi, il est plus écouté que
beaucoup de politiciens qui sont là
depuis l'avant depuis très longtemps sur
le continent qui contribuent à rouler
leur population. Moi, je risque les les
peu le peu de choses que j'ai pour un
idéal qui est l'idéal de la
souveraineté. Et ça, c'est pas une
question de noir contre blanc. Il y a
des blancs qui rêvent
d'autodétermination et je les valide
aussi. Il y a des Arabes, il y a des
Chinois, des noirs et cetera. Et la
population africaine, elle est très
sensible. En tout cas, beaucoup d'entre
eux, à la notion du sacrifice. Voilà.
Donc la pièce rapportée, visiblement,
elle est plus intégrée que beaucoup de
politiciens locaux. Euh parce que je
pense que si aujourd'hui tu vas sur le
continent et si un jour on a l'occasion,
je t'inviterai. Euh tu auras l'occasion
de voir de quelle manière nous sommes
perçus et de quelle manière eux le sont.
Nous on réunit des milliers de personnes
en Afrique euh dans chaque pays où on
va. Là, on est samedi dernier. J'étais
il y a quelques jours à peine, j'étais à
Ouagadougu, on a réuni 3000 personnes.
Euh, aucun politicien ne peut le faire
sans dépenser des millions en Afrique.
Nous, on n' pas besoin de ça parce que
les gens, ils sont à l'écoute de
quelqu'un qui risque sa vie, qui risque
les avantages qu'il a ou le peu
d'avantages qu'il a pour l'intérêt
commun.
On va repartir depuis le début. Donc,
Kemy Sebba, quel âge il a ?
J'ai 36 ans, 37 ans, décembre. J'ai pas
fini mon histoire sur les raisons qui
fait qu' m'ont incarcéré, hein. Mais
bon, si tu veux. Bon, vas-y, vas-y,
vas-y.
Juste pour terminer, donc quand je suis
revenu de toutes ces rencontres, ils ont
profité de la séance de dédicace d'un de
mes livres, je crois que c'était Black
Nilisme. Et donc, ils ont fait
réapparaître en fait le fait que j'avais
violé le contrôle judiciaire depuis
2011. De 2011 à 2014, je faisais des
allers-retours sous la surveillance de
la police. Ça leur posait pas de
problème. Mais après avoir rencontré des
Vénézuéliens et des Iraniens, ben là,
c'est devenu un problème. Et donc, ils
ont ils m'ont mis en prison en isolement
cette fois-ci à Fleurimogis.
Combien de temps ? toujours en isolement
de moi. Je crois que l'isolement et de
moi chez moi en prison, c'est une règle
chez eux.
Comment ça se passe l'isolement ? C'est
pas cool. C'est euh c'est pas cool mais
ça permet toujours, moi je suis toujours
quelqu'un qui me dit que quand quelqu'un
veut me noyer, il m'apprend la pné et
euh je me sers toujours de ces
moments-là pour être dans une démarche
introspective
et euh essayer de sortir beaucoup plus
fort. Donc je lis beaucoup, je fais du
sport et
je réfléchis au aux prochaines
stratégies que j'aurai pour être encore
plus fort quand je ressortirai. Donc en
fait ça sert à rien leur prison que ça
me permet d'être encore plus fort quand
je ressors.
Donc Kimy Sebba 37 ans.
Oui.
Marié
tout à fait.
Bigam
je sais pas ce que ça veut dire Bigam.
Ça c'est occidental. Moi j'ai deux
épouses et Tuma Sebba qui est
enseignante et Tuma. Et j'ai euh Natou
Pedro Sakumbi qui est chercheuse en
histoire, qui est nigériane congolaise.
Euh voilà, la première est camerounaise.
Je suis avec la première depuis 14 ans
et la deuxème depuis 8 ans.
Comment elle a pris la deuxème euh la
nouvelle de prendre une deuxième femme ?
Comment la nouvelle a comment reformé
l'ancienne a pris la nouvelle de la
deuxième femme ?
Non. Euh, elle sait que je suis pas
quelqu'un qui joue avec la dynamique du
mariage, que je fais tout pour ma
famille.
Et euh elle sait que c'était pas
simplement un délire de avoir d'ego pour
avoir d'ego. C'est pas le problème.
C'est euh chez nous dans la perception
africaine, dans la tradition africaine,
euh la femme est le pilier de l'homme
dans les sociétés matricinéaires et la
polygamie dans son acception occidentale
n'est pas perçu de la même façon que sur
le continent africain à bon nombre
d'endroits.
C'est c'est légal d'avoir de femmes ?
Oui. Dans nos pays.
En France,
je m'en fous. Je suis pas en France moi.
Bon alors par rapport à ça, le passeport
il est de quelle couleur ?
Non, j'ai le passeport, j'ai acquis le
passeport béninois il y a 4 ans et la
carte d'identité béninoise. J'ai laissé
la carte d'identité française et j'ai le
passeport français qui me permet de
parler aux Antilles, à mon peuple qui
m'écoute
en nombre là-bas, même si j'ai des
opposants bien évidemment aussi.
Lesquels ?
Bah tous ceux qui travaillent pour les
autorités françaises, même pas beaucoup.
et les bqués bien évidemment qui sont
les descendants d'esclavagistes qui
possèdent encore beaucoup de richesses
puisqu'ils ont 95 % des richesses alors
qu'il représente 5 % de la population
eux même pas trop mais
ça qu' a parlé créole
non je parle pas créole mais pourquoi
pas m'apprendre si toi tu veux
m'apprendre il y a pas de souci préféris
que ce soit un frère ou une sœur qui le
fasse.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que je pense qu'il aura plus de
maîtrise de sa propre langue que toi
tout simplement.
Si tu parles créole, je serais très
surpris que tu mets Bonal, on verra ça
plus tard.
Voilà, regarde. Tu vois, c'est trop
facile ça.
De quoi ?
Vas-y, parle.
Bah moi tibitain.
Vas-y,
parlons.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi
prenez en Afrique ce retour aux sources
identitaires ?
Parce que l'Afrique est la population
qui a été la première. Euh, on parle du
Nouvelle mondiale aujourd'hui, c'est un
terme à la mode, mais le mondialisme, la
première entité qu'il a rencontré dans
l'humanité, c'est la population
africaine. L'esclavage, la colonisation.
Je suis pas en train de faire la
victimisation parce que je dis toujours
que il arrive à un moment, il faut qu'on
on se regarde dans la glace, qu'on se
prenne en main. Faut pas toujours dire
que c'est la faute des autres. une
civilisation est détruite de l'extérieur
que si elle est rongée de l'intérieur.
Donc on est les premiers responsables.
Ça, il faut que ce soit clair. Mais euh
notre peuple a s'est fait laver le
cerveau
culturellement, politiquement,
intellectuellement, de telle sorte que
on a des afri une élite aujourd'hui même
africaine qui d'ailleurs est le premier
de vos problèmes. Vous avez rassumé un
de ses représentants la dernière fois
qui pense beaucoup plus en en fonction
de la bobocratie occidentale qu'en
fonction il y a pas de problème, on
revient sur tout ce qui on veut. Moi je
suis à l'ais sur tout
mais qui pense beaucoup plus par rapport
à une vision oligarchique occidentale
que par rapport aux intérêts du
prolétariat africain.
Il y a réellement un seul peuple en
Afrique ? Non, mais a plusieurs peuples
mais on a qui on a tous une racine. On a
une racine commune mais il y a
évidemment quel on a la même racine
commune toi et moi.
C'est pas la question. Si tu veux on est
des frères, on peut marcher euh nu avec
euh une tulipe dans les cheveux, il y a
pas de souci et puis on dira on est des
frèresux colur, ça peut repousser.
Mais euh
il y a plusieurs peuples, ça n'a jamais
été la question de dire il y a un seul
peuple mais il y a plusieurs peuples,
plusieurs familles qui forment un seul
ensemble. On est dans un monde
aujourd'hui où il y a les blocs
civilisationnels. Tu as le rasisme d'un
côté où les populations slaves essayent
de se réunir autour de cet idéal. Euh tu
as le bolivarisme en Amérique du Sud où
les populations d'Amérique latine
essayent de se réunir autour d'un idéal.
L'Union européenne est contestée parce
que c'est l'Union en réalité de
l'oligarchie financière qui asphyxie les
peuples européens qui souffrent
réellement. Mais le panafricanisme,
c'est une une idéologie de libération
qui veut transcender la problématique de
la balcanisation du continent africain
qui nous a été imposée en 1884 et 1885 à
Berlin. Donc
vouloir tendre vers un seul peuple ou
vers une unité de l'est à l'ouest, du
nord au sud,
c'est quelque chose qui est du domaine
du vital pour nous parce qu'on a été
détruit de A à Z et que aujourd'hui ce
sont nos propres élites qui participent
à propager cette logique de destruction.
Et dans ce dans cette démarche là, il y
a une nécessité du retour aux sources
qui doit être effectué qui ne peut
jamais être complète parce qu'on fait
partie d'un ensemble.
On fait partie, excusez-moi, d'un
ensemble qui est globalisé aujourd'hui.
Le le néolibéralisme a complètement
javellisé ou accentuer le processus de
javellisation de nos populations qui a
poussé les nôtres à un certain certaine
forme d'individualisme. Alors que dans
nos sociétés en Afrique, le solidarisme
et le le ce que Julius Nier, l'ancien
président de Tanzanie, appelé le
Loujama, le villageoisme,
c'est quelque chose qui normalement
était prépondérant. L'individu ne peut
pas être supérieur à la collectivité
structurellement parlant, mais le
néolibéralisme ou le globalisme ou le
mondialisme tel qu'on le présente
aujourd'hui a fait en sorte que dans les
grandes capitales, dans les villages,
c'est encore différents, mais il y a de
plus en plus de dérives sur le
comportement que ont les gens. Et cette
problématique que rencontrent les
africains mais les occidentaux le
rencontrent aussi. Moi, je rencontre
beaucoup de populations quand je voyage,
quand je vais rencontrer certaines
personnes et cetera, des amis ou autres,
des anciennes connaissances qui vivent
dans des campagnes qui me disent que le
aujourd'hui le le le
mondialisme en tant que tel, c'est
quelque chose qu'il est détruit aussi.
Et donc c'est pas une problématique qui
touche simplement les noirs, ça touche
tout le monde. Simplement, je crois que
nous ça nous a touché à plus grande
ampleur parce que euh l'esclavage et la
colonisation, c'est pas quelque chose
dont on sort de manière indemme, ça
c'est certain. Mais c'est un travail
qu'on doit faire sur nous-même. C'est
pas les autres le problème. Tu sais,
j'ai envie de te dire que tu vas pas
demander à vutour de se transform de se
transformer en en hibou en autre chose.
Chacun sa nature. Le capitalisme, c'est
le vautour. L'oligarchie occidentale,
c'est le vautour qui saigne son propre
peuple. Donc je vois pas pourquoi ils
vont arrêter de saigner les nôtres, mais
c'est à nous de nous organiser pour
donner un autre visage que le visage de
de de excuse-moi le terme mais du singe
savant qui aime
appliquer exactement ce qui est énoncé
ou ce qui est proné par l'oligarchie
occidentale.
Bon alors admettons qu'avec une baguette
magique,
c'est pas une baguette magique,
vous y arrivez.
C'est pas une baguette magique. C'est
des efforts, c'est des sacrifices.
Ouais, c'est peut-être des siècles aussi
mais ça fait déjà des siècles qu'on est
dedans.
Et euh
bon, admettons que ça ça fonctionne.
Ouais. C'est pour aller où ? C'est pour
faire quoi ? C'est pour une croissance ?
C'est pour quel type de valeur ?
On se retrouve nous-même.
Moi, je suis pas je vais enlever déjà un
terme, la notion de développement
m'intéresse pas parce que quand on se
développe, c'est par rapport à un
paradigme précis, par rapport à un
baromètre.
Moi, j'ai pas besoin d'un baromètre. Le
baromètre qui est fixé aujourd'hui,
c'est en gros se développer par rapport
aux nations occidentales. J'en ai
strictement rien à [__] de ressembler
aux nations occidentales, ça ne
m'intéresse pas. Mais l'Afrique a besoin
de se reparler à elle-même, de se
retrouver elle-même, de redévelopper ses
propres schémas civilisationnels, ses
propres schémas endogène. On a nos
réalités. Tout à l'heure, je t'ai parlé
de Loujama. Moi, je suis dans cette
pensée, dans cette philosophie à 2000 %,
je l'ai adapté dans notre pays. On
appelle ça alodo, c'est le solidarisme.
Alodo, dans ma langue, ça signifie
l'aide. Et euh être dans cette démarche
là, c'est le substrat originel du
continent africain.
Nos populations ont besoin de penser en
fonction de leur propre réalité, en font
besoin de penser en fonction de leurs
propres espaces, en fonction de leurs
propres environnements. Ils ont pas
besoin des histoires de PIB, ils ont pas
besoin des histoires de la Banque
mondiale, ils ont pas besoin du FMI, ils
ont pas besoin de toutes ces choses-là.
Donc c'est un travail global qui doit se
faire non pas simplement au niveau de
l'élite avec laquelle j'ai un gros
problème mais au niveau de la base. Et
donc nous ce que l'on fait à notre petit
niveau dans beaucoup de pays d'Afrique
francophone avec notre on ONG urgence
panafricaniste, c'est une démarche
bicéphale, une démarche de justice
sociale justement avec le programme
Alodo qui est soutenu par beaucoup de de
footballeurs de haut niveau, Nicolas
Anelka, Dembaba et cetera, des frères,
des amis qui comprennent le combat
politique que je mène et qui nous aident
à lancer des à créer des campagnes de
microcrédit sans intérêt pour que des
mères de famille, parce que chez nous en
Afrique, les mamans c'est les le pilier
de tout, d'accord, puisse créer des
commerces, d'accord, des entreprises qui
puisse leur permettre d'être
indépendante et de ne plus être en
difficulté économique sociale. Alors, on
ne vient pas qu'un coup de baguette
magique. On a des programmes qui sont
extrêmement structurés par des
assistants sociaux qui sont dans notre
organisation et qui suivent les maires
de famille en question. De l'autre côté,
le deuxième axe, j'ai pas parlé de
toutes les actions sociales, c'est
l'action de la souveraineté.
C'est-à-dire que il ne peut pas avoir de
justice sociale sans souveraineté. Nous,
c'est notre vision des choses. Chaque
peuple a le droit de décider de sa
propre destinée et il n'est pas
acceptable qu'au 21e siècle, notre
économie soit dirigée, décidé,
organisée, structurée par l'oligarchie
française. Et quand je dis ça, quand je
parle de l'oligarchie française, je ne
parle pas de la population française de
manière générale, d'accord ? Mais je
parle de l'élite française qui se fait
des couilles en or, excuse-moi la
crudité, en nous dépouillant, en pant
ressources minières, en pillant nos
ressources naturelles et évidemment avec
le système monétaire et économique que
nous connaissons sous la l'appellation
de Franc CFA.
Donc une fois qu'on a rassemblé tout le
monde, qu'on s'est mis tous autour de la
table, qu'on est dans des valeurs
bienveillantes,
c'est pas simplement ça. Là, tu es en
train de présenter ça de manière naïve,
je
triviale
tu en train de présenter ça de manière
triviale. Ça me fait penser au au à
certaines mamans qui se lèvent à 5h du
matin, qui sont sur des pays extrêmement
riches mais qui vivent avec moins de 100
€ par mois. D'accord. et qui parce que
euh les le pillage de nos ressources est
organisé avec les mafieux qui sont à la
tête de nos pays, les mafieux africains
donc des africains en priorité et en en
concubinage incestueux avec l'oligarchie
française, euh elle est obligée de se
lever à 5h du matin pour vendre de
l'arachide au bord de la route,
d'accord, pour essayer de nourrir ses
enfants. Donc c'est pas le trivial dont
tu parles. Moi je vois pas
je parle je parle je parle en tant que
économie continentale. Hm hm.
C'est c'est intégrer les marchés
financiers, c'est créer un autre
système, c'est avoir un système de façon
un c'est évidemment créer un autre
système. Mais avant de revenir à ça, on
parle de l'Afrique. Moi, je parle de
l'Afrique de la zone franc, l'Afrique
francophone et les Caraïbes francophones
parce que c'est la réalité dans laquelle
nous sommes. C'est une espèce
particulière. Quand tu vas dans les pays
d'Afrique anglophone, j'ai été assistant
de la parlementaire à Biqué d'Abéi au
Nigeria pendant quelques mois. Le
Nigeria, ça n'a strictement rien à voir
avec euh les pays d'Afrique francophone.
Le G bientôt être le le plus peuplé euh
3è pays le plus peuplé au monde bientôt.
Là,
tu vois, tu as les chiffres que je que
je ne connais pas et quand je ne se
connais pas, je ne parle pas. Mais ce
que je sais juste, c'est que euh le
colonialisme anglo-saxon a été très
différent de il y a l'indirect rule,
excusez-moi pour le mauvais accent, le
la règle en tout cas le rapport, il y a
une plus grosse autonomie qui a été
laissée durant le colonialisme aux pays
au aux populations africaines sous
colonialisme anglophone que dans les
pays sous colonialisme francophone où
l'humanisme, le pseudouniversalisme qui
est une inepsie intégrale en réalité euh
et qui est imposé a fait en sorte que Ça
a complètement aliéné, donc rendu
étranger à soi-même bon nombre des
nôtres dans nos pays d'Afrique
francophone. Et c'est ce qui explique
que la partie la plus colonisée sur le
continent africain, c'est pas la partie
lusophone aujourd'hui encore, c'est pas
la partie anglophone, c'est la partie
francophone. Et ça c'est en priorité à
cause de nous autres africains. Et donc
il y a un travail à faire sur ce
terrainlà. Mohamar Alkadfi pour revenir
puisque tu parles de de de schéma
économique intégré et tout ce qui s'en
suit avait proposé la problématique du
dinar or. Le but était de faire en sorte
argent.
Le but était de faire en sorte que nos
populations puissent cette fois-ci
asseoir leur monnaie sur leurs
ressources minières en tant que tel.
Quand tu regardes nos ressources, le
continent africain est l'une des terres
la plus les plus riches de la planète.
D'accord. Mais on est toujours dans une
démarche de de vouloir adosser nos
monnaies à d'autres systèmes économiques
qui ne sont pas en harmonie avec nos
réalités. Et donc le projet du dinard or
dont parlait Kaddafi pouvait permettre à
partir du moment où il y avait un
devoir, un travail de réappropriation de
nos ressources qui étaient effectuées
pouvait permettre à la population
africaine de retrouver une véritable
autodétermination. Et il voulait quoi ?
Il voulait adosser les banques centrales
à ces ressources là. donc qui est un
travail de réappropriation des richesses
qui soi organisées. Lui c'était sur l'or
parce que l'or c'est quelque chose qui
est extrêmement présent. Où était ? Je
sais pas si ça a été payé entre-temps
par les élites françaises et associées
mais il voulait adosser ça alors et il
voulait que de manière générale nos
richesses puissent être le support sur
lequel justement cette démarche
monétaire s'installe. Moi, je vais je je
me situe dans une problématique qui est
la suivante. C'est un travail à la
chaîne. Moi, je suis un acteur de la
société civil qui est entendu. Ma
responsabilité, c'était d'animer et
d'agiter ce débat qui était rendu tabou
depuis trop longtemps sur le continent
africain. Et donc, on a organisé une
croisade sur cette problématique de la
souveraineté. Et dans un des tiroirs de
la souveraineté, la souveraineté
monétaire est évidemment extrêmement
importante. Et c'est pour cette raison
qu'on a réussi, je pense, à imposer dans
le débat de société sur le continent
africain la question du fran CFA.
Il y a du racisme en Afrique.
Alors, je vais te dire quelque chose qui
va te paraître un peu borderline sans
doute, mais c'est pas trop mon souci.
Moi, les his
les histoires de racistes ne
m'intéressent pas.
Euh raciste noir blanc. Moi je suis pas
racisme noir noir.
Non mais il y a des tens il y a des
tensions. Ça existe partout. Euh ça
existe partout. Il faut pas non plus
idéaliser. Mais on appellera pas ça du
racisme. Il y a certaines régions vont
se penser meilleur que d'autres.
Il y a pas de génocide entre
communautés.
Mais à part les génocides organisés
comme au Rwanda où on sait qui sont les
responsables, euh
le génocide
à la base, c'est plus le l'impérialisme
a commis génocide là vis-à-vis des
nôtres. L'élite financière occidentale,
je dis bien l'élite est pas le
prolétariat occidental, c'est important,
a commis génocide là. Maintenant, ce
qu'il y a eu des génocides entre
africains, il y a des génocides
antfricains où tout tout si c'est
quelque chose qui a existé. Il y en a
certainement peut-être eu d'autres mais
ils sont microscopiques par rapport aux
génocides imposés par le la finance
internationale vis-à-vis des populations
africaines.
Et pour revenir sur le racisme, le
racisme ça disparaîtra jamais si ça
existe. D'accord ? l'hostilité entre des
gens de différents peuples ou même entre
des gens d'un même peuple, c'est pas le
problème. Ouais, c'est pas Rokaya Dialo
ici. Donc moi, c'est pas ça qui
m'intéresse. Par contre, l'oppression
systémique d'une élite sur d'autres
peuples, ça ça me pose problème et c'est
sur ça que je me prononce.
Bon, on a reçu Lou Maillou ici.
La gloire
et et euh vous avez fait une vidéo hm
hm mon équipe. Pas moi, j'ai pas le
temps pour ça.
C'est ça a été validé par vous ou pas ?
Tu sais euh chez nous, il y a la
démocratie directe. C'est-à-dire que
moi, je suis au village, souvent dans
mon cadre de mon travail politique,
c'est pas moi qui gère ma page fan ou ma
page publique. Il y a 500000 personnes
quasiment. J'ai pas le temps pour ça. Et
je me suis éloigné des réseaux sociaux
depuis un bout de temps. Mais j'ai une
équipe qui est à la fois sur le
continent africain et dans la diaspora
qui surveille et qui connaît le le le
Kemayou qui est quelqu'un qui vous
arnaque un peu ici en se faisant pour un
journaliste qui a pignon sur en Afrique
alors qu'en Afrique tout le monde sait
qu'il est balois. Donc euh voilà, la
réalité des faits, elle est là. Et quand
ils ont vu, on s'est jamais prononcé sur
lui en 20 ans d'activisme politique,
mais quand ils ont vu qu'il s'est permis
de raconter n'importe quoi sur nous
alors que nous on risque notre vie pour
notre souveraineté et que lui vient
manger les subsides ici en France parce
que son travail il vit en France, il vit
pas en Afrique, ben on s'est dit que je
parle au nom de l'équipe parce que je
prends mes responsabilités, on s'est dit
qu'on allait lui répondre tout
simplement.
Vous avez répondu comment ? Bah, ils ont
répondu, ils ont ils ont repris ses
propos et ils ont mis ça en parallèle
avec une dialectique, juste je termine,
une dialectique historique qui est celle
de du [__] d'intérieur qui se fait
toujours plus ro
maison,
c'est la même chose, qui euh se fait
toujours plus royaliste que le roi en
stigmatisant les personnes africaines ou
afrodescendantes qui veulent
l'autodétermination.
Et ce qui est assez marrant, c'est que
tu avais durant la période de Lumumba
des gens qui disaient que Lumumba était
un terroriste, un était un extrémiste et
un fauteur de trouble et qu'il allait il
allait nuire aux relations entre le
Congo belge et le royaume de Belgique.
On a eu des gens à l'époque de Malcomic
qui disaient que Malcomic c'était un
suprémaciste noir, un fauteur de trouble
qui était en train de semer des
divisions, des tensions entre noir et
blanc. Moi, je parle avec beaucoup de
blancs qui comprennent profondément
notre combat plus que Maoire que
Maillou. D'accord. Et nous, il y a pas
de tension entre les peuples qui se
respectent. Mais par contre, moi j'ai un
problème avec les mangeurs de subsides
qui mange dans la main de l'oligarchie
occidentale et de cette bienpensance qui
en réalité ne veut pas la souveraineté
africaine. Sinon, il serait venu se il
serait rentré au pays et il se serait
retroussé les manches pour aider sa
population. Mais il préfère être ici là
à TV5 Monde ou je sais pas où et
raconter ses inepsies. Mais il ne blague
que vous, il ne blague pas nous. Bon euh
euh il a posté un commentaire sur la
page Facebook qui a été gommé d'après
lui
mais lui quand il a il a il a il a il y
a apparemment si je ne m'abuse il y a eu
des personnes environ 15 de notre de
notre page Facebook qui nous ont écrit
pour dire qu'ils avaient laissé des
messages sur la page de Kemayou il les
avait bloqué et après lui quelques jours
après il vient écrire chez nous et il
croit qu'on va laisser. Si c'est un
homme qui est maillou moi je le vois en
direct et je le mange tout cru. Voilà,
parlons peu.
Bon, alors son message c'était "Jusqu'à
présent, je ne connaissais pas la
différence entre les [__] des champs
et les [__] de maison."
Il la connaît très bien parce que çaen
est un.
Entre parenthèses, [__] des
Champsélysées ou [__] de maison la
fille.
Ça c'est pour faire rire ses amis du
16e.
Finalement, le [__] de maison, c'est
celui qui ne vous pas un culte au gourou
Kiseba.
Le gourou Kiseba,
Paris Cochet. Tous les autres sont des
[__] des champs évidemment. C'est
vraiment la dialectique du [__] de
maison qui a bien
Ouais, vache la tête. Merci. Kim Sebba
Kimy Sebba pour cette leçon de
sémantique de la curiosité bienveillante
gloire ma gloire je te réponds en te
disant que le gourou qui est suivi par
des centaines de milliers pour ne pas
dire des millions de personnes en
Afrique c'est qui ? et moi ou c'est toi
qui n'est suivi par personne si ce n'est
ta mère et ton cousin et qui ne parle
que chez les les occidentaux mais en
Afrique on te jette des pierres parce
qu'on sait que tu as un vendu. Je me
demande c'est qui le gourou fin de la
fin de la citation ce qui concerne ce
guignol parce que je parler de lu nous
envoyé deux trois questions.
J'ai pas envie de répondre à ce clown.
S'il veut me parler, il m'invite en
débat dans sa chaîne chez les à TV5
monde et j'irai le grailler en direct.
Bon, on va quand même poser les
questions. Avez-vous des rapports avec
des mouvements comme l'exfond National
ou le cuc clan ? tu vois
qui sont loin d'avoir la sympathie pour
les noirs. Si oui, quelle est la nature
de ces rapports ?
La deuxième question. Quand vous exigez
la sortie du pays de la zone franc CFA
et le boycott des produits français,
poussez-vous votre logique jusqu'à
brûler votre passeport français et à
demander à vos camarades de lutte de
faire pareil.
Je peux je peux répondre ? Bah ouais.
Bon ce qui est intéressant, je pense que
les personnes dotées de raison verront
un petit peu le logiciel idéologique de
ce clown.
C'est-à-dire que quand Non, laisse-moi
finir. Tu tu
tu m'as pas permis de poser de lui poser
des questions directes, mais par contre
tu viens poser des questions de rigolo
dans notre échange. Donc tu me permets
que je réponde comme je le souhaite.
Avec respect, sans clown. toujours non.
Clown c'est c'est un terme français,
c'est pas une injure. Dans le
dictionnaire le petit Robert, juste pour
terminer, pour être sérieux,
cette personne-là qui est élevée par la
bobocratie de manière intégralement sur
le logiciel idéologique, dès que des
personnes prôent le souverainisme,
l'autodétermination, sont des patriotes
ou des nationalistes, ils sont
catalogués par ces gens-là d'extrême
droite. Ça me fait rire. dans le
prolétariat africain dans que que je
vous visite quotidiennement parce que
c'est ma vie, c'est ma dévotion, c'est
ma mission moi pendant que lui mange ses
petits fours, il a d'ailleurs grossi
Paris 16e. Euh il y a une chose qui est
certaine, je termine mais c'est pas non
c'est une constatation. Il y a un adage
en Afrique qui dit celui qui est
corrompu il grossit. il en ait une bonne
définition parce que je l'ai vu il y a
quelques temps quand il était aux
assédiants, il était beaucoup plus mec
que ça. Mais juste pour terminer ce que
je dis et ça me fait rire en plus et
juici de répondre comme ça sur ce type
euh moi je parle avec tout le monde, je
parle avec des gens de gauche, je parle
avec des gens de droite, je parle avec
des gens de tout le spectre politique
dans le monde. Je ne je ne suis pas
sectaire contrairement à lui qui ne peut
parler qu'aux gens que lui en tout cas
que l'oligarchie occidentale lui
autorise d'avoir comme interlocuteur
parce que c'est ça sa réalité. C'est un
mec qui est dans un logiciel
idéologique, c'est la bienpance
occidentale et c'est pour ça qu'en
Afrique ce genre de type n'est pas
respecté. Je n'ai pas de contact avec
des gens du Front National pour la
simple et unique raison que
il y a une époque où j'étais beaucoup
plus jeune, où j'étais dans un idéal par
rapport au patriotisme et je me disais
que tous les patriotes de la terre
peuvent se réunir et peuvent marcher
ensemble. J'ai compris que avec les
patriotes d'Amérique du Sud, c'est
facile. Avec les patriotes du
Moyen-Orient, c'est facile. Hbllah, Iran
et c'est facile. Mais en France,
les patriotes d'Israël,
mais si c'est patriotes d'Israël qui
veulent que les Palestiniens ne se
fassent pas voler leur terre, ça ne me
pose pas de problème. Le problème, c'est
qu'ils sont pas très nombreux. Donc
juste pour terminer euh de l'autre côté,
j'ai remarqué qu'en France certains la
plupart des patriotes, pas tous parce
que j'ai rencontré les patriotes
français qui était contre euh la
France-afrique en tant que telle. Ça
existe, il y en a et je les salue
fraternellement. Mais j'ai rencontré
aussi bon nombre, enfin bon nombre, je
les ai pas rencontré physiquement mais
je lis beaucoup, c'est une qualité et un
défaut de Français qui quand on leur
parle de la France Afrique disent "Mais
la France a le droit d'avoir sa présence
sur le continent africain." Et c'est là
je me rends compte que le patriotisme
des a une géométrie variable. Moi quand
je suis patriote, je ne veux pas la
domination de mon pays ou de ma de mon
continent.
C'est quoi votre pays ?
Comme disait Kaddafi, mon pays c'est
l'Afrique. D'accord ? Comme disait
Marcus Garvé ou Kamikruma. mon pays,
c'est l'Afrique et nos États qui sont
des États fabriqués par l'entité
coloniale ne sont que des départements.
Et donc euh pour cette démarche là, je
réponds simplement que euh j'ai
rencontré ou j'ai constaté qu'il y avait
certains patriotes français qui eux ne
voulaient pas la fin de l'hégémonie
française sur le continent africain. Et
c'est là où je dis qu'il y a une limite
dans le le dialogue ou dans l'accord. Ça
ne veut pas dire que je ferme la porte
si un un français aujourd'hui émerge en
tant que patriote et dit qu'ils veulent
l'autodétermination pour chaque peuple.
Pour l'instant, j'en ai rencontré très
peu à part des anonymes sur internet qui
ça existe donc et je parle avec des
gens, je peux parler avec des gens
d'extrême gauche de très nombreux depuis
que je suis en Afrique qui nous
soutiennent dans notre combat politique
euh moins les structures auxquelles ils
appartiennent mais à titre individuel
beaucoup. Et euh donc moi je n'ai pas je
ne suis pas secteur contrairement à lui.
Deuxième question, passeport français,
je vais être très clair. Moi je ne pas
ma réalité, mon identité contrairement à
Kemayu qui est né au Bled et qui a
demandé les papiers français. Moi j'ai
je suis né en France. D'accord.
Vous avez demandé les papiers au Bénin.
Voilà. Donc moi je demande les papiers
au Bénin pendant que lui demande les
papiers français. Par contre les papiers
français, moi je suis fichier S. Je suis
interdit de rentrer dans plusieurs pays.
Je
je suis interdit de rentrer en Suisse
parce que c'est le coffre fort des
dictateurs africains et ils savent que
si je vais là-bas ils vont C'est ce
d'ailleurs ce que les autorités suisses
ont dit hein. Ils sont venus me chercher
dans l'avion comme c'était New York et
unité spéciale en me disant vous êtes
une personne dangereuse pour l'ordre
public. vous ne pouvez pas fouler le
territoire helvétique. J'ai dit OK,
j'étais censé faire une conférence euh
au sujet de la France-afrique et donc
évidemment des coffres forts africains
dans ce pays. Euh je suis interdit de
rentrer euh que je dise pas de bêtises
au Sénégal où il y a un des plus gros
valets du néocolonialisme français sans
doute un copain de ma gloire Kayou qui
s'appelle Mackyal qui est le président
de la République sénégalaise qui dit que
mon influence est dangereuse pour
l'ordre public et que je suis en train
de tourner la jeunesse vers l'anarchie
anti française. ce qu'il appelle
antifrançaise, c'est l'oligarchie
française parce que il sait très bien en
réalité que je suis plus proche de bon
nombre de français que moi-même je suis
né en France et que c'est pas ça le
problème. Je termine et je suis interdit
aussi de rentrer au Togo parce que le
dictateur For Niassimen Yadema n'aime
pas qu'on parle de malgouvernance et de
corruption. Or, le problème de
l'Afrique, c'est pas simplement le
néocolonialisme français, c'est aussi la
corruption de nos élites qui lorsqu'il y
a un budget de 100 % vont prendre 99 %
et vont laisser 1 % pour le peuple et
encore pour le peuple. Je nuance et
enfin je suis interdit de rentrer en
Guinée parce que de la même façon,
j'avais dit que j'étais venu pour
organiser un Guinée Conakri, organiser
un meeting de lutte contre la corruption
et la malgouvernance avec les militants
locaux et comme Alpha Condé se plaint et
a peur de l'influence que j'ai en
Afrique et ben il s'est organisé pour
que je sois interdit de rentrer. Donc
voilà. Et donc si maintenant moi qui
acquis la nationalité béninoise à la
sueur de mon front parce que ça n'a pas
été facile euh je brûle le passeport
français, je ne pourrais plus aller voir
une autre partie qui compte énormément
sur moi dans le monde qui est la partie
des Antilles Guadelou parti Guyan
Réunion
euh réunion j'ai pas encore été mais ça
viendra
Mayotte
euh Mayotte non plus j'ai fait Guyane
Guadeloupe Martinique chaque pays où je
suis allé j'ai réuni des milliers de
gens sans payer qui que ce soit pour
qu'ils viennent contrairement au
politicar en France qui sont obligés de
donner de l'argent pour que les gens
viennent. Donc tout ça pour te dire que
moi la différence entre ma gloire et
moi, c'est que moi je me suis battu pour
avoir la une nationalité africaine. Lui
s'est battu pour avoir la nationalité
française et pour manger ici, vivre ici
et ne venir peut-être avec un masque sur
la tête qu'une fois par an au Cameroun
dans son village natal. Puis elle repart
à Paris. Moi, je vis en Afrique depuis 9
ans. J'y suis tout le temps. Je ne vis
pas comme un expat, je vis comme un
africain qui se conforme aux réalités
africaines. Et j'ai sacrifié un
équilibre même familial et économique
que j'avais au Sénégal où j'étais
installé, où j'avais un bon poste à la
télévision pour des convictions
politiques en brûlant le billet de
France CFA. J'ai été expulsé, j'ai été
incarcéré. Ma gloire ne peut pas
connaître ça. Donc je ne peux pas parler
avec ce genre de de clown qui a un mot
dans le dictionnaire français. Je
préfère parler avec des gens qui ont une
vision des choses un peu plus denses.
Bon, comme vous l'avez appelé clown, on
va on va reprendre une de ces questions.
Donc en fait, c'est l'interview de ma
gloire. Mais pourquoi il m'intervent pas
sur TV5 ? Alors, l'implication de Idriss
Débille, le chef d'état tchadien dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme au Sahel est
très apprécié par la France.
Tout à fait.
Et il est souvent présenté comme un
ennemi du France CFA. Pourtant, son pays
en fait toujours partie. Qu'en
pensez-vous ? Très clairement, moi je
suis là, il apprend, j'ai envie de dire
qu'il pisse dans un violon parce que
tout le monde sait cette réalité-là, que
euh Idriss Debi est quelqu'un qui a
d'abord été placé euh par la
France-Afrique. C'est évident, c'est pas
un secret. Euh il se trouve que des
proches à lui à un moment l'ont
sensibilisé sur la question du CFA et il
l'a constaté comme n'importe qui doté de
raison que c'était un scandale
politique, un scandale économique. Et je
trouve que Debi est un extraordinaire
militaire qui a un gros poids en Afrique
centrale et donc euh c'est un de pion,
il est passé à allié de la
France-Afrique.
OK. Maillou, il est pas français au fait
hein. Mais oui. Ah d'accord. Mais en
tout cas il vit ici juste pour terminer.
Ah c'est bien. Il t'appelle carrément.
Vous avez carrément le contact direct.
Vous êtes vous êtes intime, méfie-toi,
serre les fesses. Mais juste pour
terminer et pour être tu
es pas encore sorti hein, méfie-toi.
Sorti de quoi ? Ah non, c'est toi,
méfie-toi. Bref, donc il est pas
français mais en tout cas il vit en
France et c'est ici qui mange les petits
fours, pas en Afrique. Et donc peut-être
qu'il va rappeler pour dire non, je suis
là en Afrique 30 % de l'année. Mais donc
plus sérieusement,
où est-ce qu'on en était ? Parce que je
me perds avec ma gloire,
le Tchad.
Le Tchad. Donc on sait que lui Magloire
Kemayou et a déclaré que en effet Idriss
Deb était un ppion de la France-Afrique
comme des milliards d'Africains qui
pensent la même chose. Maintenant quand
quelqu'un qui se présente comme étant
une personne faisant partie du camp
opposé dit quelque chose de sensé, si
Idrce Débé
et que quand il y a le soleil il fait
jour, ben je vais pas dire queil fait
nuit sous prétexte c'est Idriss Débi. Je
ne suis pas un secteur comme Magloire
Kemayou et les maîtres qui le payent.
Voilà. Donc en effet, il s'est opposé
sur le CFA et d'ailleurs récemment, il a
un peu bégayé sur le franc CFA parce que
il y a une crise financière réelle dans
son pays et le fran CFA n'est plus son
son sa préoccupation première. Mais
quand un chef d'état parle de cette
question, bah c'est bien que des
personnes qui risquent leur vie sur le
continent, ma gloire, il sait pas trop
ce que c'est, et ben ils se sentent
soutenus par divers chefs d'état quel
qu'il soit. Et donc Kaddafi s'est
prononcé contre Franfa. Rock Marcaboré,
le président du Burkina Faso, qui m'a
qui m'a reçu euh avec beaucoup d'amour
et de fraternité le dans son dans sa
maison présidentielle me et contre le
fran CFA. Il y en a quelques-uns, ils
sont très peu et je vais pas cracher
sous un sur un soutien sous prétexte
qu'il a des bonnes relations avec
Jean-Louis Ludrian. Voilà.
Est-ce que vous êtes pour ou contre le
métissage ?
Je vais être tout aussi clair que je
l'ai toujours été.
Je suis opposé de manière systématique
au métissage industriel imposé du style
Non mais si tu me poses une question, je
réponds,
je t'explique. Béneton euh qui nous dit
en gros que le métissage c'est l'avenir
du monde et que sans métissage on pas
s'en sortir. C'est des conneries ça. Le
Brésil pendant des années a dit que
c'était le pays de la démocratie
raciale, le pays du brassage et du
métissage. On nous montrait à la télé
que Ronaldinho euh Copacabana, les
femmes bronzées en string et cetera et
puis on disait "Ah, le Brésil c'est
génial, c'est le métissage." Ben moi,
j'ai été au Brésil une fois, c'est l'un
des pays où les noirs souffrent le plus
en dehors d'Afrique en terme de
discrimination et d'ostracisation.
D'accord ? les ghetto qui a la cité de
Dieu, c'est pas qu'un film, c'est des
réalités sociales et politiques. Le
métissage ça ne gomme pas les effets
pervers de l'extrémité du néolibéralisme
globalisé qui est quelque part la
suprématie occidentale comme certains
l'appellent comme l'appelle elle
l'appelait Francis Crelsing. Elle
parlait de White Supremacy et donc le
métissage n'est pas la solution au
problèmes des au rapport entre les
différents peuples de l'humanité.
Maintenant, un individu qui rencontre
une individu euh une peut être noire,
l'autre peut être blanc, l'un peut être
noir, l'autre peut être blanche. Les
rapport entre personnes individuell, ça
ne me pose aucun problème. Je suis qui
pour parler de ça ? Mais je refuse qu'on
me dise que le métissage est la solution
aux problèmes du monde parce que c'est
des bullshits. Voilà, c'est tout. Et
moi,
j'aime la diversité. J'aime la couleur
dans sa diversité. Et si Dieu a fait
toutes les couleurs, c'est pour qu'elle
puisse se connaître, se comprendre,
s'entendre. Et je préfère un un bouquet
un bouquet de fleurs multicolore que un
bouquet de fleurs Michael Jackson avec
une seule couleur. Voilà, tout
simplement. Mais j'ai des amis qui dont
je suis très Nico, il est Marienne
Blanche, Nicolas Anelka, je peux dire
"Ah, tu es Marienne Blanche va des rétro
satanas, je suis pas stupide."
Et sa femme est une femme très bien
d'ailleurs. Je suis je parle avec des
gens de de différents horizons et ça ne
me pose aucun problème.
C'est ma mère, t'inquiète.
OK. Je crois que c'était ma gloire
encore.
Euh euh bonjour maman. Pardon. Les
enfants, tu vas les regarder comment ?
Ça va être des noirs ou ça va être des
blancs ?
On est toujours sur la question du
métissage encore. Ça t'obsti ça
ça te passionne ça ? Non, c'est pas ça.
C'est qu'on a des copains qui sont
métises et
non mais moi une bonne partie des
membres de notre ONG sont métises. Ce
que tu appelles métis, nous on les
appelle noirclair. Bob Marley comme il
disait, il était métisse mais c'était un
noir. Et dans la dans le regard de
l'autre, il reste un noir.
Et pourquoi tu dis pas blanc foncé ?
Non parce que c'est pas comme ça que le
monde les appelle et c'est pas comme ça
qu'ils sont en en l'histoire de
l'humanité. Euh tu regardes les noirs
aux États-Unis entre guillemets. Euh je
pense à Mour à Hashim Zzinga du NBPP du
New Black Panther Party. Euh tu regardes
sa tête, c'est un métis. ce que tu
appelles métis en dentel, mais dès que
tu as des ascendances africaines, ça
ressort et c'est tu es considéré comme
noir, comme [__] dans le monde dans
lequel nous vivons. C'est comme ça. Et
c'est pour ça que la la quasi totalité,
à part ceux qui sont complètement mais
la quasi totalité de ce que toi tu
appelles métis se considère comme des
noirs clairs. Va demander à Booba le
rappeur s'il se considère comme un
un blanc foncé.
Un blanc foncé. Il va dire que c'est un
noir. Bom Marley se considérer comme un
noir et c'est ce qu'ils sont des noirs
clairs, noirs foncés. Moi, je m'en fous.
En fait, le métissage ce que tu appelles
le métissage, c'est parce que le le
système dans lequel on vit est tellement
devenu barbare que on est obligé de
commenter le rapport entre les
différents peuples en tant que tel et on
veut les mettre dans des cases. Mais un
homme noir qui va faire un enfant avec
une femme blanche ou une femme noire qui
aura un enfant avec un homme blanc, elle
peut scander qu'elle est métisse en
France mais l'enfant dans la rue sera vu
comme un noir clair ou foncé, peu
importe. Voilà, c'est tout.
J'ai
je passe un bonjour à Rachel qui est ma
ma grande sœur et l'une des quatre de
notre mouvement depuis 20 ans qui est
une journaliste. D'accord. Je
dis bonjour aussi à ta mère. Non, c'est
important. Non, j'ai
dit bonjour juste avant. Voilà. Mais
peut-être qu'elle me regarde en direct,
je suis pas sûr.
Mais Rachel qui est une rasta d'ailleurs
métisse franco-congolaise et ça me fait
rire quand on parle Kemy Sebba
antimétissage s'il savait le le rôle
idéologique qu'avait cette grande sœur
dans le combat politique qui est le
mien. Et je pense qu'il rirait. Elle
elle rirait beaucoup. Elle elle rirait
en tout cas.
La religion.
La religion c'est un domaine global qui
moi qui me passionne beaucoup. Je suis
quelqu'un de profondément spirituel.
J'ai commencé
c'est mon identité, mon ADN politique.
J'ai commencé via la Nation of Islam qui
est une organisation qui a fait
connaître Mohamed Ali, qui a fait
connaître Malcomic, qui a fait connaître
Faracan. la personne qui m'a influencé
dans ce mouvement et qui est ma qui a
été ma source d'inspiration pendant les
années, même si aujourd'hui en en
vieillissant, je nuance certaines
position qu'il avait mais que j'aime
profondément qui est mon grand- frère,
c'était le docteur Khalid Abdou Mohammed
qui était le l'ancien porte-parole de la
Nation of Islam euh qui a été expulsé,
interdit pour des propos subversifs sur
l'oligarchie juive aux États-Unis.
Et euh après la Nation of Islam, je suis
rentré dans une autre branche d'un même
arbre. Il faut comprendre une chose
quand on parle de la conscience noire,
c'est que euh le panafricanisme, c'est
un tron d'arbre qui a plusieurs branches
et toutes les branches quelque part se
recoupent d'une façon ou d'une autre.
C'est un arbre avec des branches
serrées, on va dire. Et tu peux être sur
une branche et retrouver rapidement une
autre branche tout en rest en restant
dans le même espace. Donc en quittant la
Nation of Islam, j'ai je me suis
passionné pour la philosophie de ce que
l'on appelle l'aphrocentricité, le
chémitisme. Certains appellent ça pour
ceux qui maîtrisent pas trop, mais en
réalité, c'est l'affroocentricité tel
que promu par euh monsieur Caranga ou
Monéfi était à santé surtout
Cherantadiop. Ça a été la période
Tribuaca. Et puis euh le retour en
Afrique m'a permis de faire une synthèse
de tout ça et de comprendre la racine
réelle des choses. Et j'ai trouvé ça
dans la tradition africaine. Euh dans
mon pays, on parle du vaudoun en tant
que tel qui est pour moi la la tradition
primordiale donc son acception
west-africaine en tant que telle.
Tribal.
Tribal sais pas ce que ça veut dire
tribal en fait. parence
archaïque
non archaïque ça c'est c'est les vie
brûle qui aurait dit ça mais
c'est
en fait j'ai trouvé un équilibre dans
cette racine dans nos villages avec les
tradis praticiens avant c'était beaucoup
plus de reconstructionnisme idéologique
de personnes issues de la diaspora comme
les moléfiques étaient à santé et autres
que je citais mais être au contact de
des gardiens de la tradition en Afrique
m'a m'a permis de comprendre que tout ce
que j'avais étudié avant a été il y
avait il y avait des parcelles de vérité
dans tout C'est pour ça que je te
parlais de branche tout à l'heure et
l'Afrique m'a permis de compléter le
cercle. Donc aujourd'hui, je suis
beaucoup plus, je me considère comme
traditionnaliste africain, passionné de
métaphysique. Et celui qui se passionne
de métaphysique, bah il va trouver des
choses qui sont intéressantes partout.
Donc euh que ce soit dans l'islam, que
ce soit dans le christianisme, que ce
soit dans le kebranas des rastafari, que
ce soit dans les tas de choses, moi je
vois la présence une présence similaire
euh sur bon nombre de points.
Question d'internet, pourquoi l'islam
est-il le plus légitime dans le
mouvement panafricain plutôt que le
rastafarisme ?
C'est pas vrai, le rastafarisme est plus
légitime dans le mouvement panafricain
que l'islam. Le rastafarisme a été un un
support doctrinal extrêmement puissant
et je passe le bonjour à Père et Merja
qui sont des monuments du panafricanisme
francophone qui sont mes deuxièmes
parents. Euh ça a été un ciment du
panafricanisme en tant que tel. Marcus
Garvet qui est l'un des géants des pères
fondateurs du panafricanisme et
considéré comme un prophète par la
rastafarisme pour que tu comprennes un
petit peu les choses. Et euh l'islam
après est une
religion qui dans son acception
métaphysique et intellectuelle
s'opposerit d'une façon ou d'une autre à
l'idéologie dominante occidentale, au
consumérisme, au matérialisme. Quand je
dis ça, il faut pas regarder ce qui se
passe en Arabie Saoudite et au Qatar,
sinon on va avoir une autre vision. Mais
et donc du coup bon nombre de de
d'afrodescendants
se sont convertis à l'islam. Euh
d'autres moi-même je suis passé par là
par cette école pour après aller vers la
racine du continent africain qui est la
tradition africaine. En Afrique, bon
nombre aussi sont passés par ce bienlà,
certains par la colonisation ou par
l'esclavagisme parce qu'il faut aussi le
dire. Et donc non, l'islam n'est pas
plus euh
n'est pas plus validé dans le
panafricanisme que le le rastafarisme.
Maintenant, le panafricanisme, c'est
l'unité des différentes formes aussi
d'africanité. Donc moi, je suis pas un
secteur et donc je pense qu'il faut de
tout dans le panafricanisme, mais
j'estime qu'il faut un retour réel à la
racine queles que soient les les écoles
de pensée des gens. C'est important.
racine racine du type une islam
rigoriste prêché par l'Arabie Saoudite.
Ah non non, tu as pas compris en fait ce
que j'ai dit. J'ai dit que
que tu sois bon si tu veux pour te te te
rendre heureux, je veux dire je me suis
mal exprimé mais je dis que queles que
soient les tendances spirituelles ou
religieuses des gens, il est nécessaire
dans dimension panafricaniste de revenir
à la racine parce qu'on est le peuple
qui a été le plus qui a été le plus
sorti de lui-même, de sa propre
ontologie. C'est une réalité. Et donc
euh qu'il soit chrétien, qu'il soit
musulman ou autres, il est nécessaire
d'étudier notre tradition. C'est
important. Moi, j'ai décidé de rentrer
complètement dans la tradition euh et de
de tirer les expériences que j'avais
étudié au sein de Nation of Islam ou au
sein de l'Afrocentricité. Et ça me sert
encore aujourd'hui dans mon dans mon
logiciel doctrinal. Mais j'ai eu besoin
moi de retourner à cette tradition là, à
cette racine, d'être avec les anciens au
village. Pour ça que je suis très
souvent.
Le verset du trône, ça te parle ?
Le verset du trône ? Oui, ça me parle
vaguement. Mais là, tu restes dans
l'islam là. Ouais, mais pas moi.
Question d'internet. Quelle doit être la
relation entre religion et la
souveraineté ?
Une relation apaisée et une relation où
on comprend. C'est pour ça que j'aime
beaucoup René Ganon parce qu'il dit que
il y a une tradition primordiale qui est
le ciment de toutes les tendances
religieuses et spirituelles du monde.
Moi je je crois profondément à cette
tradition primordiale. J'en parlais
beaucoup d'ailleurs avec le philosophe
russe Alexandre Dougin à la différence
que lui pense que le siment de la
tradition primordiale c'est leur Asie.
Moi je pense que c'est l'Afrique. Mais
je respecte son point de vue comme il
respecte le mien et ça n'empêche pas
notre fraternité. Et je pense que
comprendre l'essence de la tradition
primordiale d'un point de vue
métaphysique, ça permettra en tout cas
en Afrique d'éviter beaucoup de tensions
religieuses, même si les tensions
religieuses sont beaucoup moins
présentes dans notre sur le continent, à
part qu'on s'est exalté, instrumentalisé
par l'armée française comme en
Centrafrique, euh beaucoup moins
présente sur le continent que par
exemple en France.
Alors question d'internet, fait-il
partie d'une quelconque société privée
cercle d'influence ? Moi non, je suis
combattu par beaucoup de sociétés
privées et c d'influence. La seule
société que je connais, c'est celle du
peuple, c'est la rue. Et c'est la seule
qui me valide. Et je suis très combattu
par toutes ces élites-là parce que je
les combats aussi euh et que je ne
ménage pas mes coups.
Comment il fin ? Ils aur dû ils auraient
dû poser de questions à ma gloire parce
que peut-être il avait des choses à te
dire sur les sociétés.
On va peut-être vous inviter tous les
deux.
Non, je parle moi je le veux sur TV5 sur
son terrain.
Le comment est financé le votre ONG
par des footballeurs ? par des artistes
à autour de combien ? Quel budget par
an, combien d'employés ? Je
pas de te dire, je sais pas, on n'est
pas au com on n'est pas au commissariat
mais euh je vais te dire simplement que
euh on reçoit beaucoup de soutien parce
que notre combat politique touche
beaucoup beaucoup. Ils se rendent
compte, moi j'ai commencé en 99 à une
époque j'étais complètement inaudible et
a une période où c'est passé dans un
total autre excès où on est devenu
extrêmement écouté sur le continent
africain et dans la diaspora. Et euh les
footballeurs, tout le monde n'est pas
bête dans le milieu du football comme
tout le monde n'est pas bête dans le
monde de manière générale. Il y a des
gens qui réfléchissent et ils ont vu ça,
ça parle avec le cœur et donc il y a
beaucoup de footballeurs qui jouent en
Europe euh dans des dans des gros clubs
parfois et qui soutiennent notre combat
politique qui donnent des gros chèqus
parfois. Ça me touche.
Le budget à hauteur de combien par an ?
Je peux pas te le dire mais il nous
permet de fonctionner.
Votre salaire c'est combien ?
Mon salaire je vais te dire très
clairement les choses. Moi je je
travaille à la télévision. Mon premier
salaire, c'est celui chroniqueur
politique. Après euh
en euro,
je veux pas te le dire, mais je me
débrouille et euh ça va. Et euh là, par
rapport à l'ONG, ça fait à peine 1 an
que je suis maintenant à pleinttemps à
côté de du travail à la télévision et je
gagne bien ma vie. Normalement pour un
africain, on va dire je suis de la
classe moyenne.
Si classe moyenne il y a en Afrique.
Mais ça va,
ça me permet de voyager partout en tout
cas
dans tous les pays.
Alors question. Est-ce qu'il peut parler
un peu de l'Orient et de l'Occident ? Il
a cité René Guénon qui a écrit dessus.
Ah ouais, très bien. Je peux en parler
des heures après, je sais pas si c'est
le sujet principal de notre combat
politique, mais pour moi l'Occident et
l'Orient, ce sont pas que des zones
géographiques, ce sont aussi des espaces
et des réalités métaphysiques.
Une qui est le monde du matérialisme, du
consumérisme le plus absolu et une
autre. Et c'est pour ça que je te dis
que c'est pas géographique parce que tu
vois au Moyen-Orient aujourd'hui, il y a
le consumérisme aussi, il y a tout, il y
a le matérialisme le plus absolu, le
plus clinquant. Il suffit que tu ailles
au Qatar ou en Arabie Saoudite, tu vois
ça. Mais et de l'autre côté, quand on
parle de l'Orient, il y a une vision de
beaucoup plus entendre et comprendre,
sonder l'invisible et sonder le
métaphysique. Et donc je n'apprécie pas
cette dichotomie ou cette cette démarche
bicéphale parce que on oppose de mondes
alors qu'en réalité le monde est plus
complexe. Je les appellerai pas Orient
ou Occident mais je je les appellerai
plutôt sociétés traditionnelles contre
sociétés modernes. Et les sociétés
modernes aujourd'hui qui sont
symbolisées par l'oligarchie d'Occident
sont en train elles-mêmes de rendre
malade leur propre population. Parce que
tu vas dans les villages chez vous en
France, moi je suis né j'ai vécu 14 ans
de ma vie dans les villages où j'ai bon
c'est d'ailleurs là où j'ai connu un
petit peu ce que ce que j'ai compris que
c'était pas facile d'être noir quand tu
es enfant. Euh mais bon, on va pas
revenir sur cet épisode là.
et ils souffrent du consumérisme aussi
parce qu'ils ont une un rapport à la
terre, ils ont un rapport au monde dans
les campagnes qui n'est pas le même que
dans les les grandes villes de France ou
d'Occident. Bien de manière encore plus
prononcée euh pour revenir à l'Afrique
parce que c'est mon sujet de
prédilection, il se trouve que le
rapport qu'on a à la terre, le rapport
qu'on a à la nature, à l'invisible, au
monde n'est pas le même que dans les
sociétés dites modernes en tant que
telle. Et donc l'opposition Occident
Orient, j'aime pas trop les appeler
ainsi parce que ça peut tromper quand on
dit ça, on a l'impression que l'Orient
ça serait les sociétés traditionnelles
et l'Occident les sociétés modernes. Or
la modernité a colonisé l'humanité dans
sa globalité à différents niveaux et à
différents degrés. Mais je parle
beaucoup plus de société traditionnelle
et de société moderne.
L'Aquarius, ça vous parle ?
Ça me parle. Moi, je Il y en a qui se
battent pour défendre la migration. Moi,
je pense que la migration saigne notre
continent.
et que notre peuple, c'est quelque chose
que je dis tout le temps quand je suis
au contact des miens dans les villages
ou dans les les grandes capitales en
Afrique francophone ou même dans la
diaspora. Je dis que mieux vaut risquer
nos vies en luttant contre les bourreaux
et nos et nos nos dictateurs à la tête
de nos États. Mieux vaut risquer nos
vies sur le continent comme nous on
essaie de le faire que risquer sa vie
pour traverser la Méditerranée et finir
esclave dans le sud de l'Italie.
travailler
sous la volonté de des multinationales
occidentales en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté quelque part, d'accord, par le
processus du dumping social. Donc moi,
je fais partie des gens qui pensent que
j'aime j'aimerais profondément et je me
bats pour ça, pour que les nôtres
restent sur le continent. On a beaucoup
de campagnes de sensibilisation sur ce
terrainlà. Alors, ma gloire Kayu va dire
"Ah, c'est vilain parce que il veut pas
que les Africains émigrent peut-être."
Mais dans la réalité des faits, on a
déjà été saigné par l'esclavage, on a
été saigné par la colonisation parce
qu'il y avait des traîtres aussi chez
nous qui ont contribué à ça, disons-le
clairement. Euh et bien pour moi
aujourd'hui, c'est de l'esclavage
moderne. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a les
multinationales occidentales qui se
mettent d'accord avec les oligarchies
chez nous, d'accord, et qui prennent de
la même façon, sauf que cette fois-ci ça
donne une sensation de volontariat, mais
le loopen prolétariat de chez nous pour
qu'il aille travailler en Occident,
sacrée quoi ? des tensions
communautaires parce que les nôtres
lorsqu'ils viennent avec un autre schéma
civilisationnel chez vous déjà dans vos
pays il y a pas de boulot pour les
populations autochtones d'autres
viennent pens qu'ils vont connaître
l'odorado ils connaissent l'enfer ça et
il y a des tensions qui peuvent être
évitables et qui sont présentes que
parce que l'oligarchie occidentale et
l'oligarchie africaine sont en
concubinage pour justement se faire un
maximum de blé
l'aarius c'est un batea que je
qui vient sauver des gens c'est bien
c'est pas bien
c'est qui vient sauver c'est qui qui dit
sauver
bah ils sont en train de boire la tasse
quand même.
Non, le le sauvetage il se situe pas là.
Le sauvetage il sit sur le terrain de la
justice sociale. La question c'est pas
parce qu'ils sont dans la mer des babtou
qui se donnent bonne conscience qui
viennent de te dire "Allez, je viens de
sauver Mamadou, tu es en train de te
noyer, viens, je vais te donner le
bonheur là-bas." C'était un petit peu
comme l'arche de Zoé qui venait
kidnapper des enfants qui disaient "On
vient sauver des enfants." Moi la
l'aquariu, je vais dire clairement les
choses, j'en ai strictement rien à
[__] OK ? Comme ça, ça te permet de
comprendre ce que je pense. Le vrai
problème, si l'Aquarius veut aider les
Africains, qu'il nous soutiennent dans
notre démarche d'autodétermination
vis-à-vis du néocolonialisme occidental,
du néocolonialisme français et vis-à-vis
des criminels que sont nos présidents à
la tête de nos États. C'est ça que
l'Aquarius devrait faire pour nous
aider. pas euh prendre ces gens et les
ramener ailleurs euh que chez eux alors
qu'ils peuvent contribuer à nous
permettre de nous enraciner et de lutter
solidement comme nous on le fait sur le
continent africain. Donc moi, désolé
pour ce discours politiquement
incorrect, mais là l'aquarius, j'en ai
strictement rien à sirer et il il
peut-être il charme la bienpensance
française ou occidentale, mais j'en ai
rien à [__] moi de l'aquarus très
clairement.
Il veut simplement sauver des gens.
Non, qui sauvent déjà les leurs. Il y a
beaucoup de SDF en France. Je comprends
pas pourquoi la Coris n'essaie pas de
sauver déjà les les SDF français qui
meurent en hiver sous - 5 degrés. Ouais,
ils sont pas en Méditerranée.
Non, mais mais l'Aquarius c'est des
Français. Non,
c'est multi multinationalité.
Ah d'accord. européenne, mais il y a
assez de gens qui meurent en France ou
en Occident qui s'en occupent et que
nous on s'occupe des nôtres. Charité
bien ordonnée commence par soi-même.
On va passer à la suite.
Toute la suite que tu veux. Tant que je
suis ici, je peux
On était à la journée de la diplomatie
et à un moment, il y a eu une escl à
propos du Gabon. Qu'est-ce qui se passe
au Gabon en ce moment ?
Au Gabon, qu'est-ce qui se passe ? La
question est très vaste. Est-ce qu'il y
a beaucoup de choses au niveau des
présidentiels ?
Non. Non. Au Gabon, il y a Ali Bongo qui
est dans le coma. Alors, le fils des
quelqu'un qui a pillé le pays pendant
très longtemps déjà et qui arrive qui
prend le pouvoir avec des élections
truquées et qui euh
C'est quoi vos sources ?
Nos sources, il faut enseigner un
minimum. Tout le monde sait qu'il y a eu
des irrégular, moi je suis journaliste
politique, il y a eu des irrégularités
lors des élections. L'Union africaine a
constaté qu'il y avait des des
irrégularités. Tout le monde l'a vu.
Donc voilà. Et ça veut pas dire que Jean
Ping est meilleur, c'est Jean Ping était
quelqu'un qui a bu à la mamelle de du
bonme pendant des années et et qui
lorsque le père est mort, parce qu'il
considérait un peu comme son père aussi
euh Omar Bongo, ben il s'est dit que
c'était pas A Bongo de prendre le
pouvoir, c'était à lui. Alors il paraît
un peu plus légitime parce que il a pas
le long Bongo mais pour moi c'est la
même racaille tous ces gens-là. Je le
dis comme je pense et je rêve et je me
bats, je travaille pour avec beaucoup de
militants locaux pour que de la société
civile émerge un nouveau leadership
d'hommes ou de femmes qui euh
permettront aux population locale de
s'autodéterminer. C'est mon seul
souhait.
K James, ça vous parle ?
Ça m'intéresse pas. C'est c'est un
fantasme chez vous en Afrique ça. C'est
pas notre sujet.
Non, mais je parle pas en Afrique.
Ça m'intéresse. Il m'intéresse pas
c'est tout.
Il m'intéresse vraiment pas. Il fait du
rap. J'ai vu qu'il était en mode chez
Gevara dans ses clips de rap. Je suis
arrivé il y a de jours, j'ai vu j'étais
en train de regarder, je crois que
c'était au calme ou je sais plus quoi ou
MTV la nuit là et non cé à l'aéroport,
excuse-moi. Et j'ai vu qu'il passait un
clip où il était habillé en Black
Panther et cetera. Moi mon combat n'est
pas un clip, c'est tout ce que j'ai à
dire.
Question internet : Est-ce que les
blancs occidentaux doivent continuer à
monter des projets de développement en
Afrique ? Confrontation big ONG,
indépendant vrai humanitaire. que les
blancs humanitaires essayent d'aider le
prolétariat français et occidental qui
souffre profondément, qui est dans des
conditions extrêmement délétaires et le
meilleur service qui puisse nous rendre,
c'est qu'il laisse les africains se
débrouiller eux-mêmes.
Question d'Internet : Envisage-t-il une
convergence des luttes entre le
populisme européen et les mouvements
panafricains ?
Moi, la convergence des luttes, je pense
que c'est la banane du siècle. Euh c'est
un mot qui a la mode en banlieu puisque
les les communistes, les marxistes, ils
ont un petit peu matrixé la rue en
Occident. Et donc on dit non, avant de
penser noir ou avant de penser arabe,
pense à classe sociale, banlieu qui va
s'allier avec les campagnes et cetera.
Moi c'est pas mon logiciel. Mon logiciel
c'est que chaque peuple essaie de
s'organiser pour son autodétermination
et si on peut se liguer, se lier et
rentrer en solidarité face à un
adversaire politique commun, on le fait.
Et donc si convergenci de lutte il y a
c'est au niveau des peuples, c'est au
niveau des résistances populaires, au
niveau des résistances des peuples, pas
au niveau micro euh entre la CGT ou les
gilets jaunes qui vont s'allier à la
banlieu et cetera et tout ce qui
s'enfuit. Moi, je crois que c'est une
banane et que malheureusement bon, nos
banlieux en France, beaucoup de gens se
sont trop longtemps laissés martrixés
par un une idéologie.
Comment je vais la présenter ? Euh,
j'ai envie de la présenter avec les bons
termes.
Une idéologie spéculative
mortifère et até que constitue à mes
yeux que ce soit le communisme ou le
socialisme. Alors, certains qui ont 20
ans ou 30 ans de retard ou 40 ans de
retard au sein de nos populations se
revendiquent du communisme ou du
marxisme. Parce que en effet durant la
période des indépendances, le marxisme
et le communisme des années 60, il y
avait un logiciel de souverainisme, de
souver d'auto d'autodétermination,
excuse-moi, réelle. Mais il y a une
réalité que l'on constate aujourd'hui,
c'est que depuis l'effondrement du mur
de Berlin, le communisme aujourd'hui est
rentré complètement dans le logiciel du
globalisme néolibéral de manière
générale, même s'il est contre un
néolibéralisme économique, il est pour
un néolibéralisme sociétal. Et nos
populations africaines n'ont pas être
confronté, n'ont pas à s'adapter que ce
soit à ce libéralisme, à ce socialisme
ou à ce communisme. Il faut qu'on se
réinvente nous-même. Et je reprends le
logiciel de Julus Niéreré qui parlait
d'une nécessité d'un socialisme endogène
et pas avoir besoin de pour paraître
intelligent de se revendiquer de Carl
Mars qui n'a jamais vécu nos réalités.
Alors autre question d'internet. Est-ce
que sépar est-ce que séparer l'Afrique
et l'Europe s'est sectarisé ? Y a-t-il
une certaine échelle de sectorisation
nécessaire ?
Non mais de toute façon géographiquement
on est séparé hein frère donc à moins
qu'ils veulent faire comme
la même terre hein quand même.
Ouais mais il y a la M des terranées qui
nous sépare. C'est toi qui a dit il y a
quelques secondes qu'il y avait des
notes certains êtres humains qui se
noyaient dedans. Donc c'est qu'il y a
une séparation et euh géographique
réelle. Et maintenant ensuite euh
l'Afrique et l'Europe, c'est pas moi qui
ai décidé d'appeler ces continents
différemment. Donc la séparation
existait avant ma naissance en 1981.
Maintenant, je dis simplement que je
pense que on a vu ce que ça a donné la
relation France-Afrique et que quand on
voit qu'il y a une sodomie continuelle
sans pensement qui est effectué, il
arrive un moment où il faut qu'on serre
les fesses tout simplement. Je te parle
avec poésie,
avec une poignée de gravier quoi.
Ouais, si tu veux.
Question internet. Thomas Sankara est
a-t-il une inspiration pour lui ?
prendre un pays et mettre en place sa
vision des choses.
C'est un grand frère que j'aime
profondément, que j'aime infiniment et
fait partie des raisons pour lesquelles
qui
s'est fait dzinguer.
On se fera on va tous mourir. Il y en a
ils vont mourir parce qu'ils ont trop
collé leurs petites comme on dit dans le
morceau. Il y en a qui vont mourir parce
qu'ils ont mangé trop de cheeseburgers.
Il y en a qui vont mourir parce que lors
d'un jogging ils vont faire une crise
cardiaque. Il y en a qui vont mourir
parce qu'ils seront rafalés. Moi, je je
vis avec la constante des menaces de
mort depuis de nombreuses années.
Par qui ?
part des gens, ils vont pas dire "Je
suis, je m'appelle Jérôme du chemin et
j'habite Neuve Pradel, mais euh par des
gens de toute tendance, des personnes
qui n'aiment pas ce que je dis sur le le
néocolonialisme français euh
et qu'il trouve que je suis dangereux
pour les relations entre
oligarchie française et Afrique de
manière générale. Il faut aussi
comprendre qu'il y a aussi des africains
qui ne veulent pas, vous en avez
interviewé un la dernière fois, qui ne
veulent pas une cessation de relation
entre la France et l'Afrique. Il y en a
qui ne veulent pas que euh le maître euh
cesse de euh de diriger la plantation.
Ben moi, je veux brûler la plantation.
Et quand on aura brûlé la plantation et
ça va venir, c'est pas un problème de
noir contre blanc, c'est un problème de
prolétariat mondial contre une élite
apatrie. Et ben quand ça va venir, on
pourra se parler de peuple à peuple avec
fraternité et les choses se feront
beaucoup plus simplement.
Fait-il une différence entre Afrique
noire et Maghreb ?
Je fais pas la différence moi, mais par
contre au Maghreb, ils font beaucoup la
différence avec l'Afrique noire. Alors
il faut pas essentialiser. Moi je fais
partie des gens qui pensent qu'il y a
des gens j'en connais parce que j'ai
fait tous ces pays aussi. dans le dans
le cadre de meeting sur le
panafricanisme, je connais des militants
panafricanismes maghrébains qui sont
très peu nombreux euh qui sont trop
discrets à mon sens et euh qui ne se
font pas assez entendre. Mais je connais
aussi une négrophobie structurelle qui
existe dans les pays du Maghreb et dans
le monde arabe depuis très longtemps. Et
dire cela ne se fait pas de moins
anti-arabe, mais je crois qu'on a le
droit de le dire. Et moi, je fais pas
partie des des gens qui sous prétexte
qu'ils sont dans une chapelle
idéologique ont peur de prononcer les
choses. Moi, je suis un homme libre. Il
y a du racisme dans le Maghreb, il y a
du racisme dans le monde arabe. Euh il y
a du racisme partout, mais déjà le noir
ne s'aime pas lui-même. Donc quand on ne
s'aime pas soi-même, parfois il faut pas
se plaindre trop que les autres ne nous
aiment pas. Et je dis toujours au nôtre
qui émigre dans ces régions-là que le
jour on se on se relèvera et qu'on ne
sera pas la serpillère de l'humanité,
les gens vont nous respecter voir nous
craindre. Mais c'est à nous d'effectuer
le premier travail. Et je reviens à ce
que je te disais au départ, une
civilisation est détruite par
l'extérieur que si elle est rongée de
l'intérieur. Donc je ne fais pas partie
des gens qui disent "Oh, des victimisés
au Maghreb, je dis aux nôtres :
"Retroçons-nous les manches,
autodéterminons nos pays, faisons de nos
pays des puissances." Il y a quelques
années, la Chine était moquée de tout le
monde. L'Inde était moquée de tout le
monde. Moi, je me souviens dans la
street, on disait l'Inde, c'est les
Indiens quand on les voyait à Garde du
Nord ou autre, on les appelait les
packpack ou les vendeurs de Maron. On
les appelait les apou Simpsons.
Aujourd'hui, l'Inde est une puissance
qui a la bombe nucléaire. C'est pas le
cas de l'Afrique. Donc je pense queil
faut prendre en humilité, arrêter de se
plaindre que tout le monde ne nous aime
pas et commencer à faire en sorte qu'on
s'aime nous-même et qu'on s'organise
nous-même. Mais quand tu as des gens qui
ont peur lorsqu'on parle de solidarité
africaine ou de solidarité noire qui ont
peur d'être taxé de communautariste, qui
disent que avant d'être noir ou avant
d'être africain, ils sont des êtres
humains, ben la défaite, elle a déjà
commencé là et ils se reconnaîtront et
c'est ça le problème en réalité.
Alors, que pensent-il du Libéria ? De
quel libérien ? A plusieurs libériens.
Libéral de Georgea, le libérien de quoi
? Qu'est-ce qu'on veut ? Quelle est la
question ?
Question internet posée comme ça.
Ah ben la démographie au Liberia. Euh
je suis pas démographe, faut appeler
comment il s'appelle l'autre ?
L'Afrique. L'Afrique va être un un des
un des continents avec un un tout
démographie le plus important.
Tout à fait.
Euh comment ça va se passer ? Est-ce que
passé du libérial à démographie de
l'Afrique ? Tu es sûr de toi ?
Ouais. Ouais. Ça fait un petit peu
longtemp
parce que si tu veux que je revienne sur
l'Afrique parce que je comprends la
question qui soutend sa question trop
vague salue je salue ce camarade quel
qu'il soit. Il veut parler du fait que
l'expérience peut-être du Liberia au
départ était malheureuse quand des
esclaves afhro-américains sont descendus
au Liberia.
Oui mais il faut parler aussi de la
manière dont les les les rapports et les
tensions
ont été instrumentalisées par la le
l'oligarchie britannique dans cette zone
parce que je vais donner un autre
exemple. Moi, je suis issu du Bénin. Au
Bénin, il y a des esclaves, entre
guillemets, j'aime pas ce terme, mais
des esclaves afro-brésiliens qui sont
revenus au Bénin. Il y a jamais eu de
guerre entre les esclaves
afro-brésiliens, moi j'en ai même dans
ma famille, d'accord, euh qui sont
revenus au Bénin et les personnes et les
populations locales, il y a jamais eu de
guerre, d'accord ? Il y a pu avoir des
périodes où chacun se regardait en
chaîne faillance et cetera. Mais
aujourd'hui, tu vas d'ailleurs le
président de de ce pays-là, c'est pas un
esclave afro-brésilien, mais c'est
quelqu'un qui est issu, je crois, de la
diaspora, Patrice Talon, il est le
président de la République du Bénin.
Donc l'histoire selon laquelle des
esclaves qui est entre guillemets
africains qui rentreraient en Afrique,
ça pourrait pas me fonctionner avec les
populations locales. C'est des
bullshits. C'est qu'il y a un exemple
qui a été créé via ce pays et tout a été
fait pour que ça échoue, pour donner la
sensation que c'était impossible. Mais
il y a des tas d'autres pays où on voit
que c'est possible.
Euh je vais demander qu'on descende un
peu les questions. Est-ce que tu peux
les Voilà
et tu salues tous les internautes ?
Ouais. Euh on est actuellement en direct
avec combien de personnes là ? Je vois
pas les gars. 3708.
Euh quels sont les intellectuels hors de
la mêlée dont tu te réclames ?
Hors de
la mêlée.
Ce qui signifie de manière plus claire.
C'est quoi hors de la mêlée ? Bah hors
de des sentiers battus, hors de du
groupe classique
déjà faudrait définir le groupe. Je suis
un relou je te précise. Je
c'est quoi pas plus que toi je pense
mais c'est quoi
gros classique ? C'est je comprends pas
en fait ta question.
Bon les intellectuels qui te font vibrer
qui ont marqué ton chemin ça doit mon
cheminà
mainstream déjà j'appelle pas j'appelle
j'aime pas l'appellation intellectuelle.
En tout cas en Afrique c'est trop
souvent synonyme de traître ou de vasal
de l'extérieur. Donc on a du mal avec
cette appellation. On on pense plus à
quelqu'un qui réfléchit de manière
générale et c'est pas limité à
l'acception d'intellectuel qui bien
souvent sont élevés dans la bienpensance
occidentale mais pas dans la réalité
africaine. Moi très clairement il y a
quelqu'un je le dis hein qui a beaucoup
marqué mon cher Antadiop évidemment qui
est un historien un scientifique
africain et un penseur africain aussi
qui a beaucoup marqué mon passage
politique et mon parcours politique.
Clairement Ralid Abdou Mohamed est ma
source prioritaire. euh d'inspiration
euh même si euh en vieillissant, je peux
avoir des nuances sur un certain nombre
de points. Nietzsche qui comme tu l'as
vu n'est pas trop de ma couleur de peau
et quelqu'un qui m'a profondément
marqué. Euh
ainsi par les aratusraas, c'est un livre
qui m'a traumatisé
et euh antéchrist aussi j'ai beaucoup
apprécié.
C'est quelqu'un qui m'a marqué dans son
rapport à l'être humain, dans son
rapport au dogme établi par la
bienpensance et la volonté de les
transcender.
Et ce sens, cette compréhension de la
force, la nécessité de la force, c'est
quelque chose qui me parle beaucoup
depuis tout. Et d'ailleurs, quand je dis
ils ont voulu me noyer, ils m'ont appris
l'apné, c'est je pense que c'est une
variante de ce qui ne tue pas en plus
fort en réalité.
Euh autres penseur qui euh
Patba Madouba m'a profondément marqué
aussi. Après, moi, la plupart du temps,
les penseurs ce sont des des leaders
politiques. C'est eux qui m'ont marqué
et là la liste est très longue. Je
pourrais te parler de
jeux pas te parler de Thomas Sankara, je
peux te parler de Auben Unobé, je peux
te parler de Patrice Leubba
qui m'ont profondément marqué, de Quamin
Chroma, de Marcus Garvet très clairement
et euh
voilà, en terme de penseur, je pense que
j'ai fait le tour. Après, il y a des
personnalités politiques qui m'ont
beaucoup touché, qui n'étaient pas
forcément noir, mais dans leur volonté
de briser les codes. Un mec comme Pim
Fortun qui pourtant est loin d'être dans
mon camp politique, qui serait s'il
était vivant un adversaire, le leader
nationaliste néerlandais qui n'aimait
pas trop les gens qui venaient les
immigrer ou autres. Euh donc j'étais pas
la question n'est pas d'être d'accord ou
pas sur le fond mais il a fait sauter
les verrou de la bienpensance et moi
j'aime bien les mecs qui font sauter les
verrou de la mienpensance. Il était
assassiné en 2002 je crois un an après
Ralid d'Adou Mohamed qui lui est décédé
officiellement d'une rupture d'un
évrisme et c'est un blanc purju mais
je je n'étais pas d'accord avec ses
idées mais j'aimais sa façon de
communiquer.
Tug life ça veut dire quoi ? Ah ça là,
tu as parlé de de l'acronyme de ma vie.
Euh la haine que tu euh
inspr d'un un petit enfant pourra
détruire n'importe qui. The AIDS, j'aime
pas parler en anglais parce que mon
anglais n'est pas bon même si je le
comprends parfaitement. ici hein.
Non mais bref, ça va être vu par
d'autres qui ont pas ta tolérance. Donc
je te l'ai traduit en français. C'est la
devise de Tupac qui a été là tout à
l'heure, tu as parlé d'un rappeur qui
m'intéresse pas trop, mais Tupac par
contre m'intéresse profondément euh
parce que
sa réalité c'était une réalité réelle du
Black Panther Party réelle. Et euh
la vie de TPAC, ça a été le parapluie
moi de ma vie quand je suis arrivé. J'ai
vécu 14 ans comme je te le disais en
province où j'ai connu une nérophobie
que tu peux pas imaginer parce que comme
disait comme dirait Bouba qui est un
capitaliste, un consumériste que je
combats totalement mais rapologiquement
je trouve meilleur que les autres qui
disait à l'époque où les noirs n'étaient
pas à la mode, ben c'est une réalité
dans les années 80 les noirs n'étaient
pas à la mode.
bien que je condamne profondément son
consumérisme et son capitalisme, je le
précise. Et j'ai morflé durant ces 14
premières années comme peu de noir en
région parisienne en morflé. Et quand je
suis arrivé en à 15 ans en banlieu
parisienne,
pour moi les contrôles de flics euh je
suis arrivé avec ma mère seule parce que
mes parents étaient éloignés
géographiquement.
Voilà, pour diverses raisons, je rentre
pas dans trop de détails.
Et euh
Mersul en banieu parisienne quand tu
arrive, c'est autre chose, c'est un
autre truc.
Et euh
j'avais un autre rapport euh à la vie.
Donc les brutalités policières, je les
ai vécu, je les ai connu, les contrôles
de police cont jeune noire en région
parisienne. Alors qu'à la base, moi je
suis issu d'une ascendance, mon père est
médecin qui a été ruiné très rapidement.
Donc il a jamais eu la vie d'un médecin
normal parce qu'il a ouvert un cabinet
quand il était jeune dans une dans une
campagne en France où être noir n'était
pas à la mode. Il a eu une fite complète
et il a m je sais pas combien d'années
pour revenir sur ses frais alors qu'il
avait il avait tellement étudié. Donc on
a jamais vécu comme les fils de médecin
qu'on aurait dû en tout cas le statut
qu'on aurait dû avoir. Pas grave. Et
quand après en plus tu es séparé de ton
père, tu vis qu'avec ta mère dans cette
région c'est pas simple. et tout a été
mon parapluie pendant
elle faisait quoi ?
Ma mère était infirmière. Elle était
infirmière. Elle faisait des Elle
travaillait la nuit, elle travaillait le
jour pour que qu'on soit bien. Euh
elle a commencé, elle était pas elle a
été infirmière au milieu de sa vie, voir
le dernier tirers de sa vie parce qu'au
départ elle était femme de ménage mais
c'est quelqu'un qui en voulait. Donc
elle a étudié étudié étudié, elle a
gravi les échelons au fur et à mesure.
En France,
elle a commencé euh Ouais, ça c'est en
France. C'est mon père qui a commencé
ses études en Afrique. Et eu donc pour
revenir à Toutac, ça été le parapluie de
mon âme. Jusqu'aujourd'hui, c'est un
homme que j'aime profondément.
Profondément et
sa musique m'a touché. Moi le rap
français me saoule en fait. Redis-moi,
redis-moi ce que ça veut dire. Tug life.
La haine que vous vous insérez dans le
la tête ou dans l'esprit des petits
enfants peut détruire n'importe qui.
Infuck.
Perfect. Véritable Frenchent, désolé
hein.
Véritable French accent.
Ouais. Désolé. Tu vois, c'est
mondialisation.
On te reproche souvent
de parler avec haine, violence. Est-ce
que tu penses que tu m'aides de la haine
et de la violence dans la tête des
jeunes black ? Ce que c'est c'est pas me
reproche souvent, c'est la bienpensance
française et africaine dit ça. Mais euh
en Afrique, tu sais ce qui est marrant,
c'est que je fais des débats politiques
de je pense de haute volet avec toutes
sortes de personnalités politiques.
Tu tapes Kemy Sebb rendez-vous, tu auras
tris/4 du temps des des bons trucs ou
Vox Africa et cetera
ou Afrique Média. Et euh on m'accuse pas
de ça. Tout le monde sait que j'ai un
discours intelligible en Afrique. C'est
que limite en Afrique, on me voit comme
un intellectuel. Mais en Occident, euh
l'élite occidentale ou les [__] qui
mangent dans sa main on te dire que je
suis un mec qui appelle à la violence et
au suprémisme.
Mais en fait, je vais te dire un truc
très sincèrement, je m'en fous
complètement.
Et je reprends l'exemple de de
Lou et Maillou. La vidéo,
je finir par croire vous avez une
liaison.
Ouais. Non, c'est pas mon Non non, c'est
pas mon type.
Eh moi je les ai je les préfère grand
avec un crâne chauve
comme Macron.
Continuons. H
donc la la
et bien membré alors si c'est comme
Macron. Mais continuons. Vas-y je
t'écoute.
Si si avec tes conneries tu m'as fait
peur de film des conneries c'est la
vérité.
De quoi Macron ?
Bref vas-y.
C'est intéressant.
Non je pense que tu es plus au courant
que moi. Tu vis ici pas moi. Mais vas-y.
Non ça nous intéresse.
Mais comme tu aimes le politiquement
correct peut-être.
la la
façon dont tu as t'exprimé ou la vidéo
sur K maillou [__] de maison [__] des
champ imagine qu'il y a un gamin qui
comprend pas la la figure
et qui plante qui maillou parce que il
pense que c'est un traître et ainsi de
suite. Les mecs, on vit dans un pays où
l'élite de ce pays bombarde des pays et
les assassines et on vient me parler moi
du risque que j'agresse des gens en 20
ans, frère, à part un policier qui a été
bousculé rapidement
par moi, jamais mes militants et
un journaliste qui a été goumé, un pote
à Bernard Henry Lévi parce qu'il avait
raconté n'importe quoi et donc il a
goûté ma bague en dehors de lui, jamais
eu d'acte de violence. Mon discours n'a
jamais entraîné des violences. Ça c'est
la criminalisation d'un discours qui
dérange. Comme je te l'ai dit, je reçois
prix sur prix sur le continent africain.
En France, je suis ostracisé au rôle de
l'extrémiste noir. On préfère les les
rappeurs qui jouent les chevevara. Eux,
ils passent dans le Figaro, TF1, tout
ça. Mais moi, je suis fiché à la section
terroriste. Ça c'est la réalité. Mais
c'est pas vrai. C'est mon discours, il
est beaucoup plus intelligible pour
celui qui prend la peine de l'étudier et
il est beaucoup plus euh comment
dirais-je ? Il est beaucoup plus
transidentitaire qu'on ne veut le
croire. Mon discours s'adapte en réalité
à tous les peuples et tous ceux qui ont
des coronesses qui ont le pantalon
chargé ou les femmes qui ont les ras
solides, elles savent ou ils savent de
quoi je parle. Mais euh les les bien
pensants de du Paris 16e ou les bouff
les bouffons et bouffonnes de BFM, c'est
sûr que eux ou de TV5 de ma gloire, eux
c'est sûr qu'ils peuvent pas m'apprécier
parce que je viens avec un autre
logiciel, je viens avec un autre
discours. Je dis à l'Africain Africain
arrête de te victimiser. Africain arrête
de faire la manche. Je dis africain
arrête de penser que c'est l'aide au
développement entre guillemets française
qui va t'aider. Africain cultive ta
terre. africain porte tes couillers. Et
quand je dis africain, je parle pas de
l'africain que du continent, je parle
aussi de l'africain de la diaspora.
Donc ce discours là ne peut pas plaire
en France parce qu'en France, je te le
dis, on aime beaucoup les noirs quand il
rap beaucoup. Le rap aujourd'hui vend
que ce soit le rap soit-disant hardcore
ou même le rap conscient qui se plaint
d'être moins entendu mais qui fait tous
les grands les masses médias, tous les
grands journaux qui qui ont des beaux
articles dans le Figaro, dans le monde,
dans la libération. Moi, je crois pas
que Tegevara ou ou
Ralid Mohamed ou autres avaient ce genre
de beau titre. Voilà. Et moi en tout
cas, je les ai pas. Et dans le même
temps, en Afrique, on vous parle de moi
pour ce que je suis, un résistant
africain qui se bat pour son peuple.
Alors, qu'est-ce c'est le plus important
? Le plus important, c'est le regard au
sein de l'Afrique. C'est pas le regard
de la presse de la bobocratie
occidentale.
Question internet. Quelles sont les
solutions pour que l'Afrique
s'autodétermine ? Quelles sont les trois
premières lois qu'il ferait qu'il ferait
voter ? Non là tu as vu là on est en
train de convoquer Nostradamus. Moi
c'est Kemy Seba. Je ne lis pas dans une
boule de cristal. Je suis pas
législateur. Moi, je suis un activateur
de la société civile. La première chose
qui va permettre à nos populations de
d'avancer quand on parle de
l'autodétermination, c'est que celle-ci
puisse euh
réactiver plus que jamais le processus
de souveraineté populaire. Cela passe
par une plus grande prise en charge des
populations et de la société civile qui
doit comprendre qu'elle est devenue au
21e siècle le nouveau centre de gravité
de pouvoir. Moi je ne crois pas je pense
qu'il y a un émettatement au 21e siècle
des élites que le pouvoir est de plus en
plus contesté parce qu'on sait que la
plupart des politiciens sont des
businessman. En Afrique, il y a un ad
qui dit que quand tu veux être homme
d'affaires, tu rentres en politique
parce que c'est meilleur moyen d'avoir
des marchés. La plupart des politiciens
rentrent en politique, ils ont pas de
voiture, ils ont rien. Ils sont en
politique, ils ont 10 hôtels, 15 maisons
et puis ils ont le poids de ils ont la
dégainine de Kemayou. Donc ça c'est une
réalité et c'est pas gratuit, il suffit
de voir cette dégain. Mais bref euh
juste mais je je soupçonne vraiment
d'avoir une liaison avec lui mais c'est
pas le plus important. Mais juste pour
juste pour terminer juste pour terminer
tu vas t'en prendre une je pense pas non
franchement je crois pas.
méfie-toi. Mais juste pour terminer,
pour être plus sérieux, euh cette prise
en charge de la société civile, cette
migration structurelle du pouvoir qui au
départ était aux mains des élites et qui
va finir par descendre vers la base va
permettre et ça ça existait partout, tu
vois, Podemos en Espagne, alors c'est
pas forcément le plus bel exemple mais
ça porte ses fruits. Le mouvement 5
étoiles, j'ai beaucoup plus de distance
avec la Ligue du Nord, mais le mouvement
5 étoiles qui à la base de BP Griot
était un mouvement antisystème issu de
la société civile euh et qui d'un point
de vue géopolitique a quand même une
vision sur bon nombre de choses
intéressantes. Après, j'ai sur le regard
qu'ils ont vis-à-vis de la migration, on
peut se questionner sur beaucoup de
choses. Euh
sont des exemples palpables que la
société civile peut prendre le pouvoir.
Et moi, c'est ce en quoi je crois.
George Choros a coopté des des des
milliers d'associations qui ont pignon
sur eux sur TV5 sur la chaîne de l'autre
ou dans les masses médias français de de
mouvements citoyens en Afrique qu'on
présente comme des mouvements citoyens
modèles. Tu vois des structures comme il
y en a marre, structures comme balet
citoyen et cetera et tout ce qui s'en
suit. Euh enfin surtout il y en a marre
parce que bala les citoyens eux ils
disent qu'ils sont pas financés par
Sorous. Donc il y a pas de problème on
va dire je les crois. Mais euh il y en a
marre et d'autres structures ont reçu
ces financements là et eux sont dans une
optique aujourd'hui quelque part de
promouvoir l'acception de la démocratie
occidentale mais qui n'est pas en
harmonie avec nos réalités. Or nous dans
il y a un deuxième axe qui part de cette
nécessité de la souveraineté au sein de
la société civile de la réappropriation
du pouvoir par le peuple. Mais quand je
te parle de ces mouvements citoyens
cooptés, financés à coup de milliards
euh ou de millions, centaines de
millions, non. Quand George Cherau se
déplace en même en personne, porte le
t-shirt de l'organisation, va au siège
du mouvement, il y va pas pour manger
des falafelles ou des kebabs ou des
chawarmaas, il y va pour financer parce
qu'il y a un agenda qui est présent. Et
il y a eu des des révolutions de couleur
en Europe de l'Est, les les révolutions
colorées, il y a eu les printes de
printemps arabes qui a été une
révolution manipulée et en Afrique
noire, il y a une révolution coopt qui
ne dit pas son nom qui est justement
cette colonisation des sociétés civiles
euh sponsorisé par USID aussi, l'Agence
française de développement et ou RFI qui
d'ailleurs c'est très intéressant ce
passage parce que RFI est une chaîne
néocoloniale par essence mais
profondément qui promeut l'agenda
français sur le continent africain.
et et c'est sa spécificité et qui euh a
réussi à maquer la plupart des artistes
africains. La plupart des artistes
africains quand ils ont besoin d'une
reconnaissance nationale, qu'est-ce
qu'ils font ? Ils sont obligés de passer
par RFI. Ça veut dire beaucoup de
choses. Et bien donc tout est fait pour
quadriller cette société civile parce
que les élites occidentales savent que
les sociétés civiles dans le au 21e
siècle dans le monde c'est les nouveaux
centres du pouvoir. Et donc là il y a un
travail aussi de décloisonnement
effectué, de décolonisation structurelle
à à à apposer sur la réalité des gens.
Et c'est ce que nous on essaie de faire
avec l'ONG urgence panafricaniste
que je dirige et aussi avec le front
ICFA qui réunit plus de 850 mouvements
citoyens sur le continent africain en
Afrique francophone et dans la diaspora.
Ça commence à bien chauffer sur le fran
CFA. Là,
je pense qu'on a une très grosse
responsabilité vis-à-vis de ça parce que
si on l'avait pas fait, petite
parenthèse pour revenir sur
l'intelligencia, la pseudointelligcia
africaine et le showbiz africain qui
sont les deux facettes d'une même pièce
de prostituée intellectuelle.
Euh quand j'ai annoncé fin 2017 qu'on
lancé une campagne sur le franc CFA,
contre le Fran CFA, qui c'était un un
débat laissé en jacher, il y avait que
les économistes qui parlaient à quatre
ou cin en vasclos parce qu'il méprise le
peuple pour la plupart du temps. Euh
la l'intelligencia africaine et
française et l'extrême gauche tendance
médiia part se sont moqués de nous. Ils
ont dit c'est des débats
d'arrière-garde, ça n'intéresse plus les
gens, c'est pas la préoccupation. Les
gens veulent juste manger sans
comprendre que le système francfa est un
système qui contribue à ce que les
nôtres n'aient pas assez à manger. Mais
moi le problème c'est que je ne cherche
jamais l'autorisation de la
pseudointelligence africaine.
J'ai dit on va lancer activité et
bénéficiant de la notoriété que j'ai sur
le continent africain grâce à la
télévision et mes années à la télévision
et aux réseaux sociaux je vais activer
des fronts simultanés de résistance
partout sur le continent. C'est quelque
chose qui n'avait jamais été fait depuis
la période des indépendances. Et je suis
même pas sûr que durant la colonisation,
les mobilisations se faisaient
simultanées parce qu'ils avaient pas les
techniques de télécommunication, les
avantages qu'on a. On a rien inventé.
Moi, j'ai rien inventé, hein, mais c'est
on bénéficie des technologies de notre
époque. Et eu bah ça a été un bingo. On
a réussi pour la première fois de
l'histoire sur le continent africain en
Afrique francophone à renir des
populations
au-delà des clivages nationaux, des
clivages techniques, ethniques,
excuse-moi. Et on a fait en sorte que le
prolétariat de tous ces pays s'est
réuni. Alors, à diverses échelles. Il y
a des endroits où c'était nombreux, il y
a des endroits où c'était pas nombreux,
mais ça a fait un boom. À côté de ça, il
y a des sud-américains qui nous ont
soutenu comme Pedro Bisky, l'ancien
directeur de la Banque centrale
d'Argentine euh qui est un un péroniste,
un militant péroniste et un
anti-impérialiste. Euh on a eu des gens
comme Alexandre Dougin et autres qui
nous soutiennent aussi et ça c'est le
plus touchant. On a réussi à faire
quelque chose de très gros, de très
grand et
donc le fran CFA, ouais, on a une très
grosse responsabilité sur ça. Même si
aujourd'hui en fait, c'est toujours la
même chose dans les les mouvements
sociaux d'envergure, c'est que le peuple
se réunit, fait le travail et après
l'oligarchie cherche toujours comment
ils essayent de tuer une mobilisation.
Ils ont ils y arrivent pas mais ils
prennent ils cooptent certains
économistes qui depuis des années rêvent
de reconnaissance. D'accord ? Ils leur
disent "Bon maintenant allez Mamadou, on
va t'écouter." Alors le fran CFA c'est
pas bien
Mamadou.
Non parce que c'est l'appellation qu'on
donne, c'est le mot global. Euh quand on
dit Mamadou, on sait que ça peut être un
Norvégien. C'est juste pour ça que je
dis ça. Je pourrais l'appeler euh euh
Ralido si tu veux ou peu importe.
Ris.
Non, régiste, si je dis régie, je suis
pas sûr qu'on va penser d'abord à un
africain. Donc voilà, même si
aimé
aimé grâce à aimer Céser, on peut penser
à Césarer, mais c'est pas dit qu'on va
penser à un homme noir. Donc juste pour
terminer ce que je dis,
tout
sain. D'ailleurs, dédicace à l'ancien
conseiller de Laurent Bagbo, Toussin, un
ami, un grand frère et à tous
l'ouverture évidemment qui est une
grande source d'inspiration pour nous si
je préfère des salines à titre
personnel.
Et euh donc à force de m'interrompre,
parfois tu peux me faire perdre mon
propos.
Ouais, d'accord. Mais donc je rebondis
en te disant que euh par rapport à tu
vois, j'ai perdu le fil. Qu'est-ce qu'on
disait ?
CFA.
Par rapport au CFA, l'élite occidentale
a récupéré certains économistes, leur a
donné des espaces pour qu'ils puissent
travailler et cetera, même certains qui
sont des anti CFA. Et aujourd'hui, le
débat franc CFA est devenu un débat
mainstream alors qu'à la base c'était
quelque chose de profondément en
rupture. Et le problème est que quand
nous on parle du CFA, quand j'ai mis ce
débat sur la table avec notre ONG, on en
a pas parlé parce que on est des
fétichistes de la monnaie. On en a parlé
parce que c'est un des tiroirs d'un
problème beaucoup plus global qui est le
manque de souveraineté. Il y a le manque
de souveraineté militaire, le manque de
souveraineté politique, le manque de
souveraineté culturelle, le manque de
souveraineté économique. Mais quand tu
parles de culture, ça peut être moins
palpable. Quand tu parles de France CFA,
c'est palpable. Et donc, on a tiré ce
premier tiroir là. Mais il y en a des
tas d'autres. Et la France, l'oligarchie
française, comprenant que le débat en
Afrique devenait stratosphérique et
qu'on avait quand même pulsé quelque
chose de très gros, ils se sont dit
mieux vaut qu'on essaie de récupérer les
choses en cooptant certains économistes
et en essayant de déradicaliser le
débat. C'est ce qui s'est passé. Mais
malheureusement la colère de la
population est trop grande vis-à-vis des
élites africaines et françaises, pas des
populations. Et de telle sorte
qu'aujourd'hui le combat s'est élargi à
la sphère donc beaucoup plus globale de
la France-Afrique.
On parle un peu réchauffement
climatique.
C'est pas trop ma cam le réchauffement
climatique et j'aime pas parler ce que
je sais pas mais comme je suis ouvert à
tout, je parle. Vas-y, allons-y.
Les flux migratoires du au réchauffement
climatique, ça va être géré comment ?
Alors moi je vais te dire une chose. Euh
la la problématique de la déforestation,
elle est plus grosse chez vous que chez
nous.
Premier point. Non, je te le dis, c'est
le
faire fact checker, hein, t'inquiète
pas.
Mais je m'en fous, si on peut se fact
checker rapidement. Moi ce que je te
dis, c'est que je te réponds, euh les
multinationales occidentales quand elles
viennent en Afrique, en effet, elles
contribuent à la déforestation. Mais
c'est pas quelque chose qui est fait
ontologiquement par nos populations
parce que le rapport à la nature des
populations africaines est très
différent de euh de du rapport à la
nature qui a en Occident. Ce qui
maintenant n'empêche pas parce que le le
problème du réchauffement climatique dit
à la déforestation, la déforestation ne
résume pas à elle seule la destruction
du climat en tant que tel. L'écologie,
elle peut être esquintée et abîmée aussi
par la l'éducation citoyenne qui fait en
sorte que beaucoup des nôtres jettent
des déchets dans les rues. Ça c'est
quelque chose qui existe et j'ai pas
besoin de fact checking ou de je de fact
je sais pas quoi pour que le savoir tout
le monde le sait et ça c'est des
démarches citoyennes qui doivent être
effectuées par les nôtres comme nous on
le fait on voulait lancer récemment mais
c'était un terrain qui était déjà occupé
à cô au Bénin campagne de nettoyage des
ordures à côte nous parce qu'on a même
pas des boueurs. les gens jettent les
sachets n'importe comment. C'est des
choses qui se font beaucoup moins dans
les villages mais qui se font dans les
capitales. On a pris des mauvais
réflexes justement du ce néolibéralisme
là. Donc les flux migratoires dû au
réchauffement climatique, ça c'est les
comment dirais-je ? C'est les peurs
peut-être qui existent en Occident. Le
problème chez nous, il se situe
autrement. Je pense euh le problème de
nos populations, c'est faire en sorte
quand on parle d'aliénation,
étymologiquement parlant alien étranger,
rendre quelqu'un étranger à soi-même,
c'est faire en sorte que les nôtres
reviennent dans leur propre corps, dans
leur propre esprit, réapprennent le
rapport à la nature. C'est pour ça que
moi, j'encourage toujours les nôtres à
revenir de manière régulière au village
parce qu'au village, on t'apprend des
choses sur le rapport à l'environnement,
sur le rapport à la terre, sur le
rapport à ton espace qui te t'éloigne du
paradigme néolibéral dans lequel on veut
t'incarcérer trop souvent dans les
grandes dans les grandes villes
africaines qui ne sont bien souvent
devenues que des répliques aujourd'hui
des capitales occidentales. Donc comment
régler ce problème en tant que tel ? Le
premier problème, on en revient toujours
à la réappropriation de soi, la
réappropriation intellectuelle,
idéologique et culturelle de soi.
Être capable de retutoyer son
environnement, d'accord ? Être en
harmonie avec son environnement, ce que
les barbares anthropologues occidentaux
appellent l'animisme en tant que tel qui
veut rien dire. Mais celui qui comprend
qui a la vie partout, qui a la vie sur
la terre, qui a la vie dans un arbre,
qui a la vie dans la nature, il va pas
l'insulter. Et ça, les sages chez nous
l'enseignent. C'est quelque chose
malheureusement qui est trop stracisé.
Et nous on fait partie de ceux qui
essayons de valoriser ça. Et c'est pour
ça que dans toutes nos mobilisations, y
compris la dernière à Wagadougu, euh on
fait on a on met un point d'honneur à
toujours faire venir les chefs
traditionnels. C'est très important.
Alors, je sais que aujourd'hui dans un
monde des religions révélées, on a
essayé de caricaturer et de mettre ces
gens-là de côté. Mais les chefs
traditionnels, quand je vais à Haïti, je
rencontre les chefs traditionnels parce
que c'est vital. Quand je vais en
Afrique, je rencontre les chefs
traditionnels parce que c'est vital. Et
eux ont une compréhension des choses
qu'il est nécessaire de prendre en
compte. Après, les chefs traditionnels,
c'est des carottes comme tout le monde.
Mais bon,
on arrive à la fin de notre interview.
Déjà, on m'a dit que c'était difficile.
Je suis surpris là.
On t'a posé des questions sur
l'antisémitisme, sur la violence, sur le
fait que tu as tabassé un gars, que des
choses comme ça, tu en veux d'autres ?
Tu veux résumer ça l'interview à ça ?
Non. Bah tu dis que c
je pense qu'on a dit quand même beaucoup
plus de choses que ça.
C'est bien. H
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
et trois livres à conseiller.
Alors je commence par euh le conseil
trois livres. Ça va être difficile parmi
tous les livres qu'il y a à conseiller.
[__] mais euh conseil au aux futures
générations.
N'attendez l'autorisation de personne
pour penser, pour exister, pour être.
Deuxème conseil, faites tout pour
protéger votre terre et protéger votre
peuple. On vit dans un monde où on ne
respecte pas les gens en fonction des
minorités qu'ils sont, minorités
agissantes dans des des dans des plus
grands ensembles. On respecte les gens
en fonction des peuples auxquels ils
appartiennent et la manière dont les
peuples se comportent. Donc comprenez
que vous faites partie d'un ensemble qui
a un devoir civilisationnel, un devoir
culturel. Moi je suis père de famille.
Je fais en sorte que mes enfants
connaissent leur histoire, connaissent
leur identité. euh connaissent
l'histoire de leur continent parce que
ma fille c'est à 12 ans, je crois que je
l'ai appris à 17 ans ou à 18 ans. Ça
c'est notre travail.
Faites tout ce qui en vote possible. Que
vous soyez chirurgien, que vous soyez
avocat, que soyez même euh chauffeur de
Uber, chauffeur de taxi, charcutier,
boucher ou agriculteur au pays et cetera
pour honorer votre terre et votre patrie
parce qu'on vit dans un monde où le
rapport à la terre c'est sacré.
Et ça c'est pas moi qui l'ai dit le
premier. Trisème conseil. Après, je
viens sur les livres.
Toujours se dire que ce que les élites
ne font pas pour le peuple, il faut que
le peuple comprenne qu'il doit le faire
lui-même. Moi, j'ai jamais attendu,
c'est la dage de notre ONG. Moi, j'ai
jamais attendu l'autorisation de qui que
ce soit pour mener mon travail
politique. Au départ, les gens se
moquaient de nous. Aujourd'hui, en
Afrique, on est plébiscité par les
masses. Et ça, c'est la plus belle des
réponses. Et dernière chose pour les
livres à conseiller, c'est très très
dur. Je conseillerai
Nation agriculture de Cherontadiop
évidemment.
Je conseillerais
Malcom X une vie de réinvention. Malcom
X Life of Reinvention, pas
l'autobiographie de Malcom X qui est une
grosse carotte parce que c'est la vision
tronquée que Alex Allé a dit alors que
le livre que je viens de citer, une vie
de réinvention et le travail de
chercheur d'un d'une éminence
académique, même si j'ai toujours du mal
avec l'académisme en tant que tel
afro-américaine qui a fait un travail de
plusieurs années Manning Marble sur la
vie de Malcomics, loin des mythes et
cetera et qu'il l'a présenté encore plus
humain en le débarrassant d'un de
certains un mensonge comme l'histoire
que quand il va à la Mec, il découvre
qu'il y a pas de couleur et donc il
devient un humaniste alors qu'il était
déjà allé à la Mec très longtemps avant
à l'époque de la Nation of Islam et
qu'il avait vu le racisme qui existait
en Arabie Saoudite à l'époque.
Et 3è livre, c'est tellement difficile.
Je dirais le consciencisme de Quamin
Chroma qui me parle profondément,
qui m'a beaucoup apporté, qui m'a
beaucoup aidé et comme j'aime pas me
limiter, je suis un relou, je vais dire
euh les danées de la terre de France
Fanon. J'aime pas trop pour noir masque
blanc parce que quelque part pour moi
Fanon et lui-même qui a diagnostiqué les
aliénations des noirs et blancs était
lui-même un aliéné.
sur un certain point, c'est mon point de
vue quand il dit que il n'y a pas de
mission noire et il n'y a pas de
culpabilité blanche. Moi, je pense en
effet qu'il y a pas de culpabilité de
tous les blancs, mais je pense que tous
les afhrodescendants et les africains
ont une mission. Ils ont le devoir de
faire en sorte que leur population
puisse se relever parce qu'on est les
derniers de l'humanité et les plus
pauvres de l'humanité alors qu'on a les
terres les plus riches. Il y a un
contresens idéologique analytique qui
n'est pas normal. Et enfin, je t'en
donne un 5è,
c'est un gros relou là. Mais je t'ai je
t'avais prévenu hein, je suis un relou
et je n'aime pas les règles. Donc quand
tu m'en dis trois, je vais faire exprès
d'en dire six et je te donne juste le
5e. Euh
moi personnellement, mes charges to the
black man
de monsieur Ja Mohamed, même si je me
suis éloigné de la Nation of Islam
depuis longtemps.
Pourquoi ?
parce que déjà du 1, j'ai du mal avec
euh les dogmatismes, tu vois, de 1. Euh
j'ai du mal avec les certains aspects
sectaristes de cette organisation. Et
puis même d'un point de vue idéologique,
il y a des choses sur lesquelles je ne
suis pas d'accord, avec lesquelles j'ai
pu l'être à une certaine époque de ma
vie. Moi, par exemple, je veux plus
essentialiser en disant le blanc et le
diable. Je pense que les choses sont
plus complexes que ça. Moi, j'ai vu des
noirs qui étaient des démons et euh j'ai
vu des blancs qui étaient des démons.
Alors maintenant, si on regarde à
l'échelle d'humanité, l'Occident, il a
foutu la merde quand même partout où il
est passé. C'est une réalité. Et donc
moi, je peux comprendre que lui, il a
voulu essentialiser une période de sa
vie. J'ai ressenti ça une période, mais
les voyages élargissent l'horizon et je
ne peux plus avoir cette exception.
Mais ce livre m'a permis de comprendre
beaucoup de choses sur la civilisation
noire originelle.
sur qui j'étais et moi je peux
comprendre que ce livre est traumatisé
Mohamed Ali qu'il est traumatisé enfin
quand il est sorti Malcomic était déjà
sorti d'un of Islam mais c'était le
résumé des enseignements d'Elja
monsieur Mohamed il m'a beaucoup parlé
et je te donne le dernier livre euh
moi qui m'a
ainsi par les aratustras de Nietzsche
Et évidemment mes ouvrages qui par la
grâce de Dieu se vendent bien en
Afrique.
Kimy Seba,
merci.
C'est moi qui vous remercie. J'espère
que vous aurez pas d'ennui pour m'avoir
invité parce que je sais qu'en France il
y a une mystérisation du débat. Je
conclurai juste en te disant une chose
que tout à l'heure on a parlé des on a
pas parlé assez.
H moi je ferai jamais la la batche pour
parler clairement
de pleurer sur un plateau. Oh, il a dit
que c'était pas bien, je m'appelle Satou
ou autre, ça m'intéresse pas.
Et moi, je je propose à Zemour un débat
quand il veut, où il veut.
Moi, je défends mon identité. Je suis
dans mon peuple, je suis dans mon pays,
tu vois. Ça me pose pas de problème
et je me bats contre des élites.
J'essentialise pas les gens. Zemour, il
les socialise les musulmans et les
africains parce que ça sert son agenda
qui veut que l'élite euh française soit
composée de deux substrats que qui sont
qui sont qui seront donc euh les les les
autochtones français, les deux souches
et les juifs contre le prolétariat
musulman.
Juifs français, c'est un truc que je
comprends pas ça.
Ouais mais bon écoute non mais il y a
les musulmans français aussi. Pourquoi
tu as pas pourquoi tu as pas réagi quand
j'ai parlé des musulmans ?
Si si.
Ah d'accord. Donc dis ça pour tout le
monde. Mais ce que je veux te dire, tu
vois, je t'ai eu là mais si je t'ai eu
parce que tu es rebondi que sur les les
juifs mais quand je t'ai dit les
musulmans, tu as pas dit mais les
musulmans français. Bon bref, donc je
termine juste en te disant que sa
stratégie est une stratégie mortifère et
le problème de Zemour ou son avantage
c'est qu'il parle face à des gens qui
ont peur de lui dire certaines choses et
qui sont non je dirai quand je serai en
face si je l'ai dit maintenant je vide
mon chargeur mais moi je te le dis
clairement si j'ai émour en face de mo
je vais l'éteindre
et je le dis au nom de mes ancêtres
merci
c'est moi qui te remercie soirée force à
vous
[Musique]